Guys?
Some, like, kaiju show is on TV.
Can't stop watching.
Oh, it's Ultraman!
No, I think this is an Ultraman ad.
Just kidding.
I was gonna say, it's Ultraman!
I'm watching an ad for gummies.
Hello everyone!
Welcome back to UnMetal!
I know I say I don't want to delay too much, because...
You know what, I actually have stuff that I really want to do today.
Because I'm not in Japan for so much longer.
But, there's one thing that I've been wanting to do, and it closes early.
So I've been like, okay, I'm gonna go do it.
Today I'm gonna go do it.
But I never get to go do it!
So...
Today I'm gonna go do it.
That's why I'm streaming just one hour earlier...
Than how I have been while in Japan.
Oh, it's back on.
The kaiju are fighting.
Is this Ultraman?
There he goes.
I put to the cube in the slot and twist and turns it.
Oh my god, Henshi...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's in the middle of the kaiju!
Oh, he's thrown down!
Wait, is this the Ultraman that...
Oh my god, this one...
Oh my god, the kaiju just exploded!
He was just walking away!
He was crawling away like...
And then the other one just faded out of existence.
There were two of them and they were fighting.
And then Ultraman came in and like literally did two taps on them.
And then they...
One of them exploded and the other one just literally faded out of existence.
What is he doing now?
He's like...
He's still looking around...
Oh my god, he's getting blasted from behind!
What the...
Oh, he's got a shield.
Oh, he's getting blasted from behind again!
By a second force!
Oh my god.
Oh no, Ultraman!
Is this the one that Arcana Project does the song for, I wonder?
There's like...
There's real people problems too.
There's some guy, he's crying and yelling at a girl.
And the girl is also crying and yelling.
He's really...
I don't have any sound on.
Sorry.
I'm really invested in this.
He's like transforming...
Again?
The cube goes into the slot.
And then he's...
He's turning it!
Yeah, he's turning it!
Where was that child's drawing?
Oh my god, he's got armor now.
He's got Ultra Armor.
Some creature just woke up.
What is this?
He's coming out of the ground.
Or he's peeking from the ground.
Oh my gosh, Ultraman!
Oh, the guy that faded is actually invisible!
Oh, and they're still attacking him!
But what if that one guy literally exploded though?
Ultraman can take both hits with his arms.
He's got little shields on his arms now.
Oh, there's lots of explosion.
Oh, rip this town.
Oh, the Kaiju are hugging.
They went after him.
And then he like jumped in the air.
Because he was like, haha, too slow.
And then they bumped into each other.
Oh, he just like summoned a sword.
And then...
Oh...
He cut them in half!
And then they exploded into fireworks!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, this guy and this girl are still yelling at each other.
Maybe.
She looks... she's smiling now.
I think they're happy that the... that the beasts were destroyed.
And he still looks really upset.
I think he's still crying.
I don't know why.
She's talking to him.
She's calming him down.
Yelling while Kaiju fight.
Yeah!
Audio description on.
Oh, she's crying, but she's smiling.
She's just like, yeah, it's okay.
Oh!
Ultraman's here, but like...
Not in Ultra.
This is the best way to experience cable TV.
Wait, what time is it?
This is probably over in like...
A couple minutes, right?
Oh my god.
He's walking over to her.
Oh, he's doing that like drive-by talking.
You know, where he like...
Walks over...
You know like what they do in like drama and Japanese drama and stuff?
Where like...
They'll walk over to someone.
And they'll stand next to them.
But they won't look at them.
And then he'll...
They'll say something.
And walk away all serious, you know?
Oh, he just did that.
And she started crying even more.
Oh my god.
She's sobbing.
What did you say to her?
I should turn on the volume.
I think he said she hates us.
Wait.
Are they...
That's her teacher.
I think she had a crush on her teacher.
Wait, but she's in a Seifuku and this is definitely college.
Wait.
What's going on?
She's in a Seifuku this whole time.
This is like a love montage.
What's going...
But that's a teacher.
Oh.
Huh?
Is she like a genius?
Maybe she went to school early.
And she fell in love with her teacher.
Whatever this little robot guy is, I love him so much.
He kind of looks like a Pokemon.
There's like this one beetle Pokemon that's blue.
Looks like her.
Maybe she's cosplaying the whole time.
Yeah, this is a little scandalous.
This is on my...
Children's...
This is like children's prime time TV, you know?
Okay, she's wiping her tears.
She's over it.
She's like, okay.
We have like actual issues.
Like monsters destroying the city.
Oh, she's smiling.
Oh, wait, she's...
She turned around to look at him.
Oh, she knows she's looking at the robot.
And she's smiling at him.
I think she likes him more.
Are you watching Kamen Rider?
I'm watching Ultraman.
And she's walking away with the robot.
Good end, actually better end.
You know what, maybe she becomes a robot lover.
You know, just like me.
And the robot is showing what happened.
Here's the credits, hold on, I have to listen to the credits.
Yeah, it's Arcana Project, I knew it!
Oh, I love this song.
Yeah, it's showing like a montage of her in school, but she's like in a college room.
I think she's in love with her professor.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, listening to my favorite, one of my favorite idol groups while watching kaiju fight is like really surreal, actually.
Unmeddle!
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to exit out of the game.
Create a clone of Mike!
Is this what we were doing?
No.
Wait, huh?
Oh, is that what we were doing?
Oh, clone Mike to fool the cameras.
Yes, okay, I was like, I know.
I know we have to fool the cameras here.
And then, how do I do that?
Just finished, pass VOD and yes.
Thanks for watching the VOD.
Do you think this tree is punchable too?
Now there's anime on the TV.
Oh my God, what is this?
It looks so cute.
Tensui no...
What is this?
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Oh, it's the row girl, it's row boats.
Okay, I gotta stop watching TV.
Okay.
Okay, there's so many cameras around here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Probably get his attention with a coin, right?
Oh, we have no, who stole our coins?
What?
Did we throw our coins?
Throw our coins away.
No way.
I had so many coins.
What happened?
I'm not quite sure what to do here.
I didn't give them to the man.
I gave him $10 million.
Okay, hold on.
Oh look, I become invisible.
I become invisible.
Wait, you can't see me.
There, I'm invisible.
I'm invisible.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, wait.
He can't be...
He can't...
Uh oh, wait.
Um...
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
You're contradicting yourself.
Sergeant, execute this liar.
Yes, sir.
Oh my God, they just shot me.
How am I supposed to do this part?
Create a clone of Mike.
Hold on, I'm gonna...
I think our codec...
I think...
Jesse here.
Oh, my God.
Over.
Yeah, the guy is maybe Dunzo.
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear you.
No, I need...
What?
I need help.
No, that's not...
What else do I have in here?
I have some reeds.
Palm trees.
Um...
Let's see.
How am I supposed to create?
I created!
What is it?
Tied reeds.
What did I just make?
Do I...
I think I must put his clothes on this thing.
Blair Witch.
For real though, actually.
I think I have to put his clothes on this thing.
Wait, your clothes.
Clothes.
Shit.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
You're contradicting yourself.
Sergeant, execute this liar.
Chloroform in his head.
Yes, sir.
Ooh.
I'm just trying to voodoo doll you.
Why can't I just take his clothes?
Okay.
Chloroform.
How do I chloroform again?
You want to try using the chicken hat?
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Um...
Combine.
It must be something with this, right?
Probably.
And then...
Oh, shit.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
You're contradicting yourself.
Sergeant...
I got everything you need now.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-bum.
But once I pass him out...
Combine it with something else, maybe.
I'm trying to use it to, like...
Put the sunglasses.
No.
Do you have a different way of doing that?
Hey...
No!
I'm trying to figure it out.
Yeah.
You can move bodies.
Yeah, but it's, like...
They say if...
If he's not on screen...
I think the alarm still goes off.
Yeah, I see.
Unless I just stand here with him.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
We just stand here with him.
I mean, that's obviously not the case.
Do I just stand here behind him?
Maybe?
I don't know.
Let me try... when I'm holding him, maybe I press C.
Maybe I press C while I'm holding him, you know?
So let me combine this.
And then... select it, and then while we're chloroforming him...
We... hold it.
We hold it, maybe.
C.
No.
Ah!
Why?
It didn't work!
It was my B-Day!
Last year, my Kamiyoshi sang Sanchi... Sanchi Pidgey.
But she died.
Oh.
Can I ask you for some U-Nya, gay horse?
U-Nya!
Koba, happy birthday!
I don't know what to do here.
Has anyone played this?
Can I get a hint?
I just woke up, and honestly, not feeling so well today, so...
Just mentally.
Not physically.
What if I... can I... will it see me here?
Yeah.
What the?
There's an exclamation point there!
Oh!
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Is there a person there?
Behind the tree?
Interesting.
Let me combine this.
And then re-save.
I have played, there's a uniform you can steal somewhere else.
Okay!
Thank you!
Find a spare uniform.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Go go go go go go!
Maybe here?
Oh wait, how am I supposed to get past the both of them?
Oh, never mind.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my-
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Great start to the stream, I suppose.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Awww...
What?
You, you, you...
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Oh my god, please shut the hell up.
I don't want to listen to you anymore.
Stupid general guy, whoever.
No!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sound?
What?
It's turned!
Didn't you say that the alou- It was looking the other way, are you kidding me?
No way.
I'm about to turn off the voices for this guy for real.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Wouldn't it be able to...
Maybe here I can do it.
Okay.
Uniform!
I got bullets.
I got a uniform!
I got another uniform!
Okay.
Oh, it's saved.
It's saved.
Okay.
Now if I combine...
With our...
We have a guard clone!
And we have...
Two of them!
Yeah!
Even in the dark.
Or from afar.
Looks like a real live guard.
We created a clone.
Real Metal Gear.
Liquid Mike.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay.
Thank goodness the game is a little...
Um...
Generous sometimes.
Okay.
Shoo!
Oh wait.
I should have gone.
My bad.
Wait, but now they're looking in like the same direction.
Wait, I can't go.
Okay.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Hey Minto, I have a question.
Didn't you say the alarm never sounded?
This game...
This game is trying to kill me.
I don't think it can see me.
I don't think it can see me here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Noob!
Contradicting.
I'm just full of contradictions.
Oh my gosh.
Go.
Only guards in the shell core carry AKs.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
We made it!
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's go wash.
Let's go water closet.
Yippee!
Okay.
What?
We'll take care of that other room.
Another time.
Oh!
I forgot to combine.
La la la la.
Oh.
La la.
Set up the clown!
Shit.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Why didn't it?
I think I was robbing him instead.
Okay.
But this is fine.
Because combine.
Combine.
With this.
And then combine.
And then...
Combine.
There we go.
Didn't you say the alarm never sounded?
Didn't you say?
The alarm?
Didn't you say the alarm never sounded?
Set it up!
Didn't you say... the alarm never sounded?
Okay, I'm gonna try and get the medal now.
Time to... time to... time to play God.
Yeah!
I'm gonna go save again.
Didn't you say the alarm never sounded?
Oh my gosh, it's an ad for Precunet and ReZero!
I miss Precunet so much.
Pain.
Pain, pain, pain, pain.
Okay.
Actually, since we're right here...
There we go.
Now we won't have to go all the way back to the bathroom.
Shit.
And...
Oh, shit!
It's a two-tap for X, isn't it?
To carry the guys?
Okay, okay.
Didn't you say... didn't you say... I said nothing!
I said nothing, I said nothing, I said nothing, I said nothing.
I said nothing, I said nothing, I said nothing...
I said absolutely...
Nothing.
And then...
Got it.
I'm just gonna move him, like, right here.
I'm scared to go, though.
Okay, we'll wait.
We'll wait for it to re-psyc- re- redo its, uh...
There we go.
Okay.
Oh!
What's in here?
Wait!
What's in... Grenades!
Electromagnetic grenades!
Wait!
Oh no.
We got the chaff grenades.
Chaff's real.
If I use it right here...
Disables any electronic devices for three seconds!
Secret.
Is there a secret in there?
Hold on.
The tree.
Here we go.
Very eco-friendly.
I know.
I'm destroying trees.
What happened to you, Jessie?
Jessie, you've changed.
You're destroying trees now.
That was never you!
What about this tree?
No.
Okay, let's go.
Wasn't there a tree here?
There never was a tree.
It's all in your imagination.
It's all just... secret.
It's all just...
But there's a guy here.
Up there, isn't there?
It said...
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
You're contrad...
Huh?
But it's... what's that three...
Oh, I have to, like...
Oh, it's not, like, a general...
Wait, do I have to...
I have to, like, aim it?
Disables any...
I have to, like...
Oh!
I thought it was just, like, a...
Spray and pray, like, whatever.
I thought it was, like, a...
You know, I'm used to Metal Gear, you guys.
So I actually have to aim at it.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
Oh...
I'm pretty sure you said...
Oh, I didn't say anything!
I'm not contradicting myself.
That's really short.
That's, like, extremely short.
I couldn't even have time to break the box!
Um...
I didn't even have time to break the box.
Okay.
Huh!
Oh, shit.
Hahaha!
Didn't you say that the alarm never...
Is that voice line gonna drive you crazy?
Yeah.
Actually.
Not quite in the mood for it today, but you know?
It's fine.
Everything's okay.
Okay.
Didn't you say that the alarm never sounded?
You're contradicting...
That's how I feel about that.
Yeah...
Hahaha.
I wish I could, like, shoot the, um...
The cameras.
If I can disable them...
Why can't I just shoot them dead?
Okay.
Thank you!
Oh, my gosh.
I don't trust myself.
Didn't you say that the alarm never...
Wait, after successfully selling my GPU and PS5...
Don't tell me if you're being financially irresponsible.
What are you talking about?
Probably have to roll to get to those crates fast.
Oh, maybe!
Maybe, maybe, maybe I have to...
Look guys, I'm punching you!
Punch chat, punch!
Punch chat!
Get punched!
Sorry, because if there's a guy behind the tree, I'm just kind of trying to guess what to do is all.
Because I see his little exclamation point.
You know, when he sees me.
Maybe I have to shoot him dead.
Maybe I have to blow him up.
Okay.
I'm going to save real quick.
I don't feel like running back and forth, you know?
Just one of those things.
Oh gosh, it didn't work.
Oh, I can stand here though.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I can stand there and not be seen.
I thought it had a wider cone.
A wider radius, you know?
Even if I have to do it several times.
Okay, okay, okay.
We made it!
Yippee!
Okay, but what do I do about this guy over here?
I'm behind a tree.
I can't reach this one.
Hmm.
No, no, no.
I can't punch the tree either.
What if I shoot the man?
What if I shoot him?
Damn.
Reload.
I'm trying to shoot through the tree.
There could be no one there.
Oh.
Why did I always see an exclamation point right here?
Wait, what just happened?
Oh!
What's this?
It wasn't wise to use weapons there.
Oh, okay.
I got more grenades.
Stamina!
Destroy it.
Is there anything I can do in here?
Oh, okay.
A secret room for real?
I just knew about it because of the exclamation point.
Oh, then there never was any guy there.
I'm just actually crazy?
Oh, wait.
How do I...
I have a key.
No, wait!
This is too difficult!
How am I supposed to...
How am I supposed to get around and down?
Save.
That's a good idea.
Wire cutter.
Will it work?
Nah, it doesn't work.
That was...
That's really big brain thinking though.
I feel like that should have worked.
Oh!
What the...
Oh, I did Wasta instead of Up.
Okay.
This one is... tricky!
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I have to do it.
Like from here, I think.
Hey!
No.
Wait.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
Hey!
Um...
I don't know.
I'm just... I'm just nervous now.
So I'll do it anyway.
What?
Punch.
Punch, punch.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
All right.
All right, all right.
Okay.
Let's save again.
Just save it again, you know.
All right.
Cool.
I only have five left.
There it was.
The entrance to the Omega building.
That would be the last place I'd visit on my tour de escape.
Tour de escape.
Enter the door without raising any suspicion.
Oh, it saved for me.
Dang it.
No suspicion.
No suspicion will be caused.
Obviously.
Oh.
Okay.
I want the trash can.
Pizza box.
Wait.
Open up to see what's inside.
I carefully studied that pizza box, examining every detail, every clue, every molecule.
I deduced that it was used by someone else to smuggle something into the Omega building.
A pizza?
A pizza.
Exactly.
A pepperoni pizza to be precise.
A pizza.
A financially responsible wisp.
Thanks for being such a supportive and amazing goshi.
If I hold it...
I carefully studied that pizza box.
Oh, oh.
My bad.
If I hold it, then maybe I can also get in.
Right?
Punch.
I carefully studied that pizza box, examining every detail, every clue, every molecule.
No.
I keep pressing the wrong thing.
Okay.
I got an extinguisher.
I can't use it, though.
Can I combine?
Combine.
I have a smoking pizza!
Oh my gosh.
I have...
I was so hungry that I ate the pepperoni bits left over on the cardboard.
Ew.
But I'm not hungry.
But as I opened the box, the steam from within disappeared.
Oh.
Pepperoni.
Okay.
Hold on.
Then we have to combine it again.
Okay.
Now we have a hot smoking fresh pizza.
Right?
Yes.
Pizza delivery!
Pizza!
Ooh.
That was close.
Pizza!
Pizza delivery!
If I just go, will it work?
Or do I have to...
Do I...
Um...
Do I have to disable it?
It could just...
Potentially just work.
Ah!
It's P!
Pizza!
Mike!
Oh.
P!
Yeah.
I show you the pizza.
I show you the... look at that.
Steaming.
Pepperoni!
He liked it!
Arugula.
Yippee!
Perfect!
You guys perfect stage.
Look at us.
Chapter 9.
Jericho's heart.
As I crossed the door, I entered into the Omega Building.
The heart of Operation Jericho.
The Omegaverse.
It was a cold, dark, industrial place.
Perfect.
With containers and barrels everywhere.
On my right, there was the control room where they monitored the outer cameras.
And, of course...
The asshole that controlled them.
Oh, I was gonna say there's nobody in there.
The guy I tricked with the pizza.
Who was coming over to get it.
Reality was going to hit him in the face.
Quite literally.
Give me the fucking pizza and get out.
Don't be rude!
You are, friend.
I'm not your friend, buddy.
What the fuck?
It doesn't weigh shit.
Son of a bitch.
Punch him!
Kill him!
It's empty.
Where the hell is my pizza?
Look at what's on the box.
What's on the box?
Where?
I was inside the Omega Building.
I just had to reach the rooftop and pray that I'd find a helicopter.
I was hoping he would do like the fist through the...
The fist through the...
Through the box.
I'm glad that he did not disappoint.
I'm so glad.
Nothing.
I'm gonna destroy these, though.
As I destroyed that computer.
I'm so glad.
I saw something curious inside its metal guts.
Metal guts?
It was a thick cable and a sign that said, Ground Floor Alarm Cable.
Do not cut.
I can cut that.
Cut the alarm.
Okay, cut that.
I can cut that.
Done.
With the cable cut, the alarm wouldn't be triggered on this floor.
Even if I was detected, guards wouldn't be able to trigger the alarm.
Yeah, baby!
I'm destroying everything here!
Kill the lights!
Wait, so, do I not have to be stealthy anymore, or...?
They put a lot of effort into the security of that compound.
Yeah?
The guards weren't the typical ones I've encountered before.
Oh, no.
They were monkeys!
They were.
Oh.
Scandinavian!
Exterminators?
Like a bug exterminator?
Or...
They were Scandinavians!
I'm scared.
What if I do exterminator?
Let's do...
Um...
Scandinavian.
Scandinavian guards.
Oh!
Not only were they tougher than normal guards, they were light sleepers, too.
No, do they wake up?
Is he gonna wake up eventually?
Do they wake back?
Oh!
Ow!
Oh, shoot.
Uh...
You can use string to tie up a Scandinavian guard before they wake up.
Oh!
I don't have any, though!
And I'm bleeding out.
I used all my string on the stupid Blair Witch Project.
Um...
Let's...
Ouch!
I'm in a loop.
Oops!
I fell asleep.
This is so stupid.
Noooo!
Oops!
I fell asleep.
Okay.
Oh, they're just chilling where they are at, though.
Maybe it's okay.
Okay?
Oops!
Oops, I fell asleep.
Come on, look this way.
There we go.
Oh my gosh, we leveled up!
It could be demolition, man!
Grenades and rockets deal 25% more damage, or...
Actually, you recover health slowly when not bleeding!
Wait, that's huge!
That's huge!
I want to take out those other guys.
Hi.
What's in here?
Oh!
Lots of rope!
There's a little freaky in here.
A little freaky indeed.
A little freaky indeed!
Mint's a fan of Shibari.
I didn't spend my formative years reading Nanotakaru for nothing.
In class!
You know.
You know how it is.
What's on this side?
I can probably...
Oh wait, but they're like both looking this way, aren't they?
Elemental evil sadistic laugh.
In class!
I do not know...
how it is.
That's okay.
Wait, how am I supposed to go to...
Shit.
I'm a prisoner!
Sit back down.
No!
Wait!
Oh.
Um.
Actually,
this is okay.
And the reason I say it's okay is because we learn about the string.
So, all I do...
All I got to do is get the string.
They put a lot of effort into...
Scandinavian guards.
Okay.
The string is up above.
So what we can do is...
Do this.
And then...
Wait.
Oh shit.
Like so.
Right?
Ah!
See on me.
And then...
See on you.
I mean...
Wait.
No!
Why didn't it work?
There we go.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh.
I just gotta level up.
See on me.
See on you.
Okay.
We're fine.
Everything's all good.
See?
I made it work.
In the end, I got it to work.
Okay.
And then...
Select.
See.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
Oh no, I didn't level up though.
No!
I need to become Action Hero!
Alright.
Let's re-get the stuff that I just lost.
We're all good.
Yeah.
I missed the star this time.
So sad.
This looks suspicious.
We'll come back.
Ignore the blood.
Water closet.
Yippee!
Okay.
And break everything.
Can't let them be happy.
Okay.
Oh.
And it's...
Okay.
I have two.
It's an elevator.
Okay.
What's over here?
I know there's two guys here.
Interesting.
Oh.
I need a...
Card four.
Level four card key.
This guy is just wandering around.
I don't have any... anything to distract these guys anymore.
Hmm.
I wonder if I should also start blasting...
Hahaha!
Would a gun do better than my fists?
Can you knock on the wall?
I don't think so.
No.
Perfect!
Action hero!
There we go.
I truly am an action hero.
With that, that was...
That was pretty action-y, I'll be honest.
And I'm hel- Look, I'm gaining health!
I'm gaining health!
Oh, this is so good.
Wait, he's like looking straight at me.
Now that I think about it.
How do I want to go about this?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
We're okay!
Did I tie him up?
Yeah, I tied him up.
Yeah, he's all tied up.
Little room.
I found a few crates.
A few crates.
Okay.
They contained.
They contained!
Um...
I don't know what I need the most of.
Rockets, maybe?
Why do I need rockets right now, though?
Rockets.
I have, um... I have five first aid kits.
I only have one rocket.
I can't even hold them.
Are you kidding me?
I can only hold two rockets at a time.
This guy...
I have one rope.
Give me a...
Oh, I wish one of the options was rope.
Metal!
Yeah, more rope!
Yeah, more rope.
Yay!
Yo, yo, yo!
Okay, nice.
We can hear your keypad.
Good.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Is this guy gonna be looking straight at me?
Actually, I'm gonna save real quick.
Just in case.
I have no fear with the rope!
When I have rope, I have no fear.
More of these.
I wonder what we'll need them for.
I love attacking.
What's this here?
I was the only one without a triangle!
Secret blood bag.
Oh.
Lots of bullets.
Okay, let's take it.
I don't know what the blood bag's for.
It's kinda scary.
Fills your HP more instantly!
Nice.
Let's go!
Secret!
Oh, this is this room.
I guess let's just go.
For it?
More rope.
Uh-huh.
What's down here?
Yeah, yeah.
The blood bag is one of the most important items on the speedrun.
Can remove 2 to 3 minutes.
Oh my gosh!
Oh yeah.
That's right.
We can't go in here.
Have I explored everywhere?
Except...
What was in here?
I know I went in here.
But what was in here?
Oh, just whatever.
I think I have to go to the elevator.
To the elevator.
How many... okay, I got two strings?
For these guys?
I got two...
Perfect.
Okay, how do I want to handle these guys though?
Coin?
I don't have any more coins.
I think we threw them away.
Otherwise I'd be like, yeah, coin!
Grenade.
We could grenade them.
We could nade them.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Shoot the wall on the other side?
Will that actually do anything?
Okay.
Now we're all bleeding out.
So, me first.
And then you guys, okay?
Oh, shoot.
And then I tie you up.
Oops.
Oh my god, no!
This is messed up!
Hold on!
Order of operations or something!
Oh, shoot.
And then I tie you up.
And then I bandage myself.
Oh, gosh!
Oops.
I fell asleep.
Why did you...
You just got shot and you wake up immediately after I heal you!
Oops.
I fell asleep.
Two months in for me.
The best is yet to come.
Viridian, thank you!
Let's up versus down.
I'm scared.
Let's go down.
Into the basement.
Oh!
You think he's friendly?
Welcome to the basement.
Uh, thanks.
Who are you?
I'm the Lord of the Labyrinth.
If I hadn't had enough already, a mental patient escaped from a ward.
I played along.
I'm Fox, son of Zox.
I hail you, the Lord of the Labyrinth.
What's behind that door?
A dark labyrinth filled with deadly trash.
Oh, no!
Why did they build a maze down here?
They didn't.
The labyrinth already existed.
Mysterious.
This building was built over an old prison.
Why the prison?
Which was built over ancient catacombs.
Oh, which was built over...
It is said that the souls of the prisoners...
Wait, there's ghosts down there!
Are you trying to scare me with that children's story?
It is merely a warning.
Such is the esteemed duty of the Lord of the Labyrinth.
I was curious about what was inside the labyrinth.
Me too, I'm curious, I'm curious.
But I had no business in these catacombs.
No, the catacombs.
We can escape through the catacombs!
So I didn't think about those ridiculous stories.
Although later, I'd be back.
Do you wish to enter the labyrinth?
Yes.
No, thank you.
Don't speak for me, Jesse Fox!
Son of Zox.
Do not speak for me.
Oh wait, I didn't check to see if we could go down any further.
Hold on, I'm just going to check real quick.
I want to go in there!
Please!
Okay, let's go up.
Stinky socks.
No stinky socks.
I'm a little frightened about what's going to be in there though.
To be honest.
Oh wait, the alarm is still on this floor.
Before we go any further, let's go up.
See what else we can see.
Okay, this one requires a key.
Looks like there's some...
experiments going on in here.
Okay.
Alright, let's go check this one.
But I don't know what the alarms are like.
So I guess we'll see.
Why did it save?
Freeze!
What happened with Dr. Hoffman is kind of long to explain.
Do you want me to summarize it?
Tell us everything.
Don't even think about it.
Any detail can be crucial.
Don't skip anything.
Now, I want you to drop that fissile core uranium 235 isotope sample.
Okay.
How in the world do you know that it's a fissile core uranium 235 isotope sample?
What else would be in the hands of a scientist whose expertise is in fissile core uranium 235?
Oh, they're just going to keep saying it.
Oh no.
How do you know I'm a scientist whose expertise is in fissile core uranium 235 isotopes?
I know everything about Operation Geronimo.
Now, drop that sample.
Do you know what will happen if I drop this and the flask is broken?
Of course I know.
The alienation will flood the whole room.
He's handling it without gloves.
I know.
I'm not telling you to literally drop it.
I mean slowly set it on the table.
It's okay.
Don't get nervous.
Same to you.
Okay.
Now turn around.
Slowly.
I'm afraid I can't turn around slowly.
Why not?
Because we're working in a 2D environment.
I can only turn in multiples of 90 degrees.
Turn around 90 degrees twice.
But slowly, but slowly.
You're the brains behind it all.
You won't get away with this, you sick bastard.
Operation Jericho will die with you.
With you?
Is everything okay, Dr. Hoffman?
Oh, gosh.
He has a weapon.
Yeah, I do.
Wait.
You said Dr. Hoffman.
Is your surname Hoffman?
Yes.
Why?
What's up?
I had a neighbor called Hoffman.
He was tall, German, and hairy.
No way.
He won the lottery, but died of gonorrhea.
That's right.
Oh, man.
Yes.
Life can be cruel sometimes.
Oh, it's not the same guy?
Are you sure?
But enough stories.
What's the purity of the isotope you're using?
Oh, this must be the long version, you know?
Are you mad?
That purity is highly unstable.
How does he know so much?
You need to generate an absolute void field and contain that isotope in an electromagnetic field.
I'm kind of getting hungry.
That's what we do.
We have containers of 500 megajoules.
They're explaining everything.
Oh, my God.
A rabble like you invented the H-bomb.
You disgust me.
Hold on.
H as in Hoffman.
Hydrogen.
Oh, my God.
This is some real, like, game theory levels of thinking.
Don't try to confuse me with your scientific slang.
Whether or not you're the mind behind this, you're the accomplice of a nuclear menace.
Say goodbye, Dr. Hoffman.
Wait.
I did it against my will.
Against?
They have my daughter.
If I don't do what they say, they'll kill her.
Your daughter?
Where are they keeping her?
They have her working as a doctor.
Wait.
We know that hot doctor.
The same one where I met the doctor.
Suddenly, I pieced things together and everything made sense.
Oh, my God.
There were two doctors in that building.
I never saw this man's daughter.
Doctor, how old is she?
Hot.
Somewhere in her 30s.
In her 30s?
What kind of answer is that?
A good father would say she turned 32 last April 31st.
April only has 30 days.
Don't change the subject.
What sort of father are you?
It's okay.
I confess I've never been a good father since I've spent all my time absorbed in science.
Uh-oh.
Who's calling me?
Who's calling you, Dr. Hoffman?
Excuse me one moment.
Hello, honey.
This is not a good time.
It's never a good time for you, Dad.
I know.
It's her.
But my current situation is particularly disastrous.
Why?
Because a man is pointing his gun at me.
What?
Who is he?
I don't know.
He doesn't seem like he's from here.
I want to go get my cake, but I don't want to miss the dialogue.
Well, the cake is my breakfast, basically.
I got it last night and I couldn't finish it.
But I'm hungry.
It's the only thing I've got.
Are you Jesse Fox?
Yes.
It's him.
Damn it all to hell.
Do you know him?
Honey?
Are you there?
Hello?
It's a mill crave, you know?
Oh, now she's calling me.
Now it's mine.
Hello?
Jesse Fox here.
Over.
Can you tell me what the hell you're doing?
Doctor, hey, hello.
How are you?
Not very happy.
Knowing that you're aiming a gun at my father.
Oh, he was telling the truth.
Your... your father?
Yes.
Doctor.
Doctor?
This is not your father.
What do you mean?
Of course he is.
That's what they're trying to get us to believe.
In truth, he's the father of another doctor that works in your building.
What?
There are no other doctors.
I'm the only one here.
They're trying to make us believe that, too.
They're manipulating us.
Is your father, by any chance, an expert in nuclear chemistry who works in the Omega building?
He's something.
He's really something.
The evidence finally collapsed in on itself.
Besides two doctors, there were two scientist fathers.
The one in front of me who also had a doctor daughter and the doctor's father.
Really?
Then explain something to me.
I'm starting to get confused.
How is it possible that someone like you, dedicated to looking after others, has a father that is involved in the annihilation of millions of people?
What are you saying?
My father is a good man.
He's a brilliant scientist, not a killer.
Well, the man in front of me is working with uranium for nuclear weapons that will be used to annihilate entire cities.
What is...
I think Jesse is a little silly.
You see?
I told you he wasn't your father.
What should I do?
Do I kill him?
What?
No!
Tell him that...
Doctor, I can't understand you if you cover your mouth.
Doctor, shut up.
Why did you tell her?
Now my own daughter will hate me.
Don't worry.
She wasn't your daughter.
She was the other doctor.
What are you talking about?
They're the same person.
That's what they're trying to make us believe.
You're toying with us.
Are you really doing this for your daughter?
Yes.
I want her to be safe.
Millions of people could die.
I prefer the deaths of millions of people over the death of my precious daughter.
You're a monster.
It's not called being a monster.
It's called being a father.
If you had a daughter, you would understand Mr. Fox.
Enough!
That was really something.
Don't be an asshole.
I know that.
I mean, how do I reach the rooftop?
And don't stall me, understood?
Another stupid answer and I shoot.
I don't think you'll do it.
You don't look like an assassin.
I got rookie's eyes.
It was an accident.
It was
eating.
It's fine.
It is but a scratch.
Come on, my friend.
Stand up.
The blood.
I'm going to repeat the question one last time.
And this time, I won't miss.
Excuse me.
You didn't miss.
You hit me.
That's true.
Then this time, I won't heal anyone.
Yeah.
And how do I reach the rooftop?
There is a lift that reaches the rooftop.
You just have to keep going up as much as you can.
Okay, I did that.
But you will need a level 4 access card to go out.
Oh, no.
Give me your access card.
Give me a level 4 access card.
If we don't have one, we just have level 3 access cards.
I swear.
But you're scientists.
I'll have to search for it.
Now.
Continue working as if nothing happened.
Nothing happened.
Do something suspicious.
Nothing.
You'll kill us.
Promise the doctor not to kill anyone.
Huffman's daughter.
The other one.
You had no intention to shoot me, right?
No.
You see?
I told you that you didn't look like an assassin.
Why did you?
Jesse, no!
You can't imagine how much I hate myself for what they're forcing me to do.
In the end, I talked to them about my escape.
About Colonel Harris.
And the promise I made to him to call the cavalry if I managed to escape.
That gave Dr. Huffman and his team some small hope of rescue.
I wonder how short the short version of the explanation is.
That would be used in Operation Jericho for as long as he could.
After that, I asked him for some assistance in my escape.
But he was terrified of being discovered.
Which would compromise his daughter's safety.
So he decided to stay neutral.
But still volunteered some information.
Okay, okay.
Take the info.
What's the info?
Let's go save.
That was... quite silly.
And the blood on the floor.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
Joy!
Thank you for the 200!
Thank you for the Hakasuba!
Holy moly!
Thank you!
Why?
Another thing.
Don't shoot in the lab.
Most of these devices don't react well to bullets.
Okay.
I won't.
Shoot.
Act like nothing happened.
Yeah.
You're not going inside, are you?
I'm just going to have a quick look.
Yeah.
What's in there?
Microwave hallway!
Oh my god.
There's beetles in here?
What the hell?
Why are there...
I have...
I threw out my thermal suit too.
Who are you?
I like the music in here.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Be careful in there.
There are patrols of mechanical spiders.
They can see in every direction.
What?
They may be shut down somehow.
Only with an electromagnetic grenade.
But it would only last a few seconds.
Enough time to let them taste my fists.
My fists.
Please, carry on with your genocide work.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do I get in here?
Okay.
Alright, kaboom, kabowee.
Yeah.
I don't mind the spiders so much right now.
Mechorachnophobia.
Snake?
No, this is Jessie.
I mind the spiders.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is messed up!
This is messed up!
They follow, they follow, they follow, they follow!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I mind the spiders.
I mind the spiders now.
Wait.
Okay.
What do I need to...
Let's just go.
Be careful in there.
Okay.
My goodness.
My goodness, goodness, goodness.
And they follow.
And
they follow.
He said a few seconds but he didn't elaborate.
How much is a few seconds?
You know, like...
Like three seconds like the cameras?
Or what?
I'm scared of that.
Three seconds just like the cameras?
Raid of mecha spiders.
Probably three like the cameras.
Alright, just before that.
Just before that, you know.
Hold on.
Yeah.
Okay.
Re-punch everything?
Oh, you know it.
I'm destroying their research!
Okay.
Now we know.
I missed.
It's okay.
I gotta be careful because I can see on all sides.
So it's more like just kind of waiting it out for him to come back.
Come on, little spider!
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait!
Okay, we got him.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Are you okay?
Is your wallet okay?
Please.
Thank you though!
Thank you!
Two of them.
Oh...
What if I punch this?
Radiation.
I think I missed my window of opportunity.
For some of this.
Look at them!
They need them to group up like that.
Wait!
It's wasted!
No... Oh, dang it.
I
thought he would go down, you know, or to the right instead.
No!
Nooo!
Oh, now you go over to the right, you asshole!
You son of a bitch, you...
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
Yeah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Hold on, there was a... I'm gonna grab this grenade just in case.
Just in case I need another one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm also... Nah, I'll just save with a...
...a toilet.
Destroy, destroy, destroy!
Vivi, go away!
Thanks for the gift!
Did you watch the new Beetlejuice?
Is it good?
I just noticed your profile picture as well.
That's why I'm wondering.
Does anyone watch the new Beetlejuice?
It's fine.
It's good, yeah?
You liked it?
We got our anti-rod suit!
And now we're good to go.
That's pretty good.
This looks like it could be a secret.
If you punch long enough...
If you destroy any wall, any wall could be a secret.
Minto juice, minto juice, minto juice.
Just watching it was alright, yeah?
Did it feel like a good...
What's the word?
Mr. Fox!
I'm coming!
Like a good, you know...
What's up, Hoffman?
My daughter.
She is not replying.
Continuation?
I guess sequel?
I don't know.
Faithful remake?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh, Joy!
Too many coincidences.
That cow!
What if they killed her?
Why would they do that?
If they do, you no longer have a reason to continue your work here.
That's not the point here, Jesse.
But, rely on us and wait a while.
And remember to delay those nuclear warheads as much as you can.
God knows what will happen if they get completed.
Yeah!
Angel, thanks for the gift then!
Thank you!
Thank you guys so much!
Really appreciate it.
That's me punching the air.
Yeah!
Hit the robot!
Thanks for the gift then.
Okay.
We got to put on our suit.
And we can't...
Oh no, we can't punch in the suit.
Are you going inside?
I'm just going to have a quick look.
Thank you for the five gift then.
Casey, thanks for the gift then.
So wear the anti-rat suit the entire time.
Oh wait.
Okay, thanks for the gift then!
Thank you guys!
Oh crap.
I can't throw...
I can't throw bombs either.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the 50 gift then.
What is happening?
What is going on?
Oh, I have to...
Okay, I have to take it off.
Throw it.
Take it off.
Punch.
I see.
But I recover HP.
So actually this isn't so bad.
I think.
Maybe.
Oh, I missed my chance.
But I...
It's really the amount of grenades.
I might need more.
Which is the issue.
That's the issue.
Jesus, thanks for the five gift then.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
Is he going to come over here?
Oh my god.
Object!
Thank you for the 20!
What's going on?
Nice, nice, nice!
Nice!
What is happening?
Why is everybody getting gifted?
Here.
Punch, punch, punch!
Thank you!
This guy is right here.
Okay, hold on.
Just saying!
Thank you for the 20!
What's happening?
Goose!
Thank you for the 20.
Thanks for the 10.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for the gifted!
Ducky, thanks for the five!
I have 10!
Oh!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
I missed my chance.
Yay!
Enjoy!
Thank you for the 50!
What is going on?!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you guys so, so much!
What is happening?
My butt.
My birthday isn't until... the end of this month!
Oh my gosh!
You guys, my birthday is coming up.
It's been like three years since I've celebrated my birthday.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you!
Wait
for birthdays.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Thank you so much, but please.
It's okay.
You don't have to do it.
You don't have to give.
It's okay.
It's okay!
Let's go October!
Yeah!
Joy.
Joy, your wallet.
Seriously.
I really appreciate it, but please.
Please don't feel like you have to.
Please don't feel like you have to!
Thank you so much, but please!
Oh man.
Not the cameras again.
Wait, I only have one...
One left.
Uh-oh.
Thank you so much for all the gifts.
You guys, thank you!
There's too many names for even for me to see.
I'll try and say some.
Um, Farinibus, thank you!
Um...
Uh...
Dima, thank you!
ThatA, thank you!
Chain Thunderbolt, thank you!
Um...
Valonie, thank you!
Kumoichi, thank you!
FakeNee, thank you!
iX300, thank you!
TryPhrases, thank you!
PaperBox, thank you!
CasterRaptor, thank you!
I'd Rather Not, thank you!
Ivan, thank you!
ViridianDelta, thank you!
Trollkin, thank you!
Kenja, thank you!
Rysta, thank you!
Nexidama, thank you!
HistoryMaster, thank you!
C2, thank you!
Gumball, thank you!
RockBearEver, thank you!
LostInTheStory, thank you!
InvisibleMoose, thank you!
I think I got all of them.
I think.
I hope.
If I missed you, I'm so sorry.
BlueEyesHunterDragon, thank you!
Take this!
Critical hit.
Seriously.
NO!
Hey, Fox, you there?
Yeah.
Here I am.
Garlim hele!
Thank you for the I don't think you're home.
The radio signal wouldn't reach...
I'm in the Omega building.
Fuck, man!
Why they're prepping the nukes?
Yeah...
You decide to stop them.
What a change of heart man.
Yeah.
No, it wasn't intentional.
Then why the hell are you there?
I'm...
We even bought a boat.
Oh shoot.
What?
They're coming in!
Oh, we're so... You guys, this is it.
It's so over.
It's so over!
I wish I could be a box!
Oh my god, there's so many guys here.
Where do I need to restart from?
No.
Wait.
Oh no!
Are you kidding me right now?
No way!
I should have saved before I got... I thought it saved.
I should have saved.
I don't think I can avoid the spiders.
Because they follow me when they see me and they also see in all directions, you know?
So... I think it's best if I actually just destroy them.
Oh shoot.
That was close.
Actually, no.
I wouldn't be able to make it.
We'll wait for him to come up here.
No...
Do they see infinitely far?
That I do not know.
That I'm not sure about.
But...
When I... If I kill a couple, I can like go and...
You know...
Go and save or something.
Afterwards, you know?
I think we have to wait for this guy to come back over here.
Yeah.
No biggie.
Oh, never mind.
I thought he was gonna go up.
The gifts are still going.
I know they're like clogging up the chat.
Oh shoot.
I forgot to put on my thing.
Okay.
Now I'll go save.
I'll go save just so that we have...
I know I can save with the potty.
Like the porta potty.
But it's okay.
It's fine.
Probably.
It's probably fine.
You need to go potty?
Yeah.
Well...
If you got gifted a membership...
You know...
I sometimes post little hints and stuff.
I have future things.
So...
You know...
Maybe some hints have been posted.
Maybe...
As of recent...
As of...
Today?
Who knows?
I don't know.
So you can go check the community tab.
And stuff.
I don't know.
If you want.
It's cool.
If you don't want to either.
Whatever.
Hint hint.
Whatever could it mean?
And look!
I have three left now!
I actually have more than I did before.
Okay.
There's just one in here.
So we at least need to save it for that one.
How do I want to time this?
Hmm...
What did you send?
Oh.
Just your name.
Go stop.
Okay.
Let's go.
What is their name?
You guys, just ignore.
Just ignore.
I think like here.
Yeah!
Okay, we saw this part.
We saw that part.
Now I'm gonna save again.
Nice!
Oh,
I didn't get to destroy those.
Guys, this is bad.
This is bad.
I don't have any more grenades.
Oh, wait.
I have more grenades!
Yippee!
I have more grenades.
But how to?
How to?
This is cyborg.
Thanks for the 500.
How to?
How...
Oh, wait.
I can just walk under, can't I?
And then...
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I just... I shoot or I do this.
And then we gotta punch real fast.
Real fast, real furious.
Oh,
I can't... Oh my god!
That scared me.
Let's go.
And these guys aren't Scandinavian.
So they don't need...
They can just fall asleep.
Oh, no.
He's not Scandinavian, so he doesn't need the rope.
Dang it.
I wanted to rope him.
Save?
Oh, I guess I can save here, can't I?
Now that I've put that guy to sleep, huh?
There we go.
Nice.
Thanks for reminding me.
That was so close!
Oopsie!
I keep wanting to... I keep wanting to chloroform them instead of pressing X.
You know?
It's just a silly habit.
Oh, this room looks important.
There's operations materials in here.
For sure.
I'll find it.
I got...
Oh!
KGS protocol.
Oh.
Huh?
Okay.
Level four!
We found the access card floor.
This was the access card I needed to reach the rooftop.
Yippee!
Now I just had to check if there were any helicopters up there.
Yes.
Saved, baby, saved.
These guys are still down.
We can now check in here.
This is a high room.
Oh!
Jagerical.
Files.
Cigarettes.
Other stuff.
The world.
The fifth document was a shopping list.
A shopping list?
A collection of military vehicles they bought from the Soviet Union when it collapsed.
Oh.
Not eggs.
Trucks.
Tanks.
Armored vehicles.
Helicopters.
Oh.
I thought like a grocery list.
And nuclear submarines.
Submarines like the one that attacked us.
They attacked me.
Now they have one less.
The fourth document was the logbook of a mini rescue submarine.
Okay.
We know all these other ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bread, butter, milk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now this guy we have to coin.
This is a guy that gets a coin.
Hey!
A coin!
A grenade!
Oh!
Okay.
This is gonna sound really stupid but I'm going to go all the way back and I'm going to save.
Actually I have to put this back.
Because I don't know when the next cutscene is going to happen, but I want to free up my toilets, essentially.
I want to free up my toilets.
So that I can...
Never mind!
I changed my mind about that.
Let's just...
It'll save, probably.
Never mind!
I just...
That's not what I wanted to do.
Anyway.
I want that.
Do you think they'll see me?
Oh, a coin!
Hey, a coin!
Me first.
Then you guys.
I didn't mean to heal myself.
I'm so stupid.
I did not mean to heal myself!
I got the coin, though.
Photographs!
On a desk.
I had a look at them.
Because, you know...
I was born curious.
Wait.
Curious?
Don't you mean nosy?
I'm bored.
There were shots of some guys loading something big onto trucks.
Oh my gosh!
It's his photographs!
Something that looked like...
Concrete blocks!
Fuck.
Thank you.
These were the photos Robert was taking just before he was captured.
We got his photos!
We got his photos.
See, it was worth.
It was worth, maybe.
Oh.
Okay.
Look at this graph.
Every time it makes me a graph.
Hold on.
There was a kit over here.
Yeah.
I'm going to grab this.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Let's talk to Robert.
Robert!
I got your photos.
I hear you.
Guess what I found.
Yeah.
The love of your life.
And your photos.
Oh, really?
They didn't destroy them?
No.
They must have Diogenes syndrome.
What?
Are you saying my pics are trash?
Man.
These pictures leave a lot to be desired.
Oh, yeah.
Why are you such a jerk, Jesse?
Did you take them with one of those disposable cardboard cameras?
You're such an ass.
Only the smartest of them.
Oh, my God.
Take them with you, my friend.
I hope they help you for something.
Will do.
Over and out.
We have the evidence.
Because we went for the coin.
Jesse, why are you being such a smart ass, huh?
Oh, we're back here.
Oh, my God.
That means this is the lab which takes me to the party.
Yeah.
A full loop.
Perfect.
Let's reload and then save.
I keep pressing the hotkey on accident, which I never use.
Oh.
But you know.
Alright.
Time to go... to the roof.
To the wall!
To the roof!
Let's see.
Fun fact, if you wear the sunglasses, Jesse won't go for the coin and he can get the photos without an alert.
No way!
That's what the- I've been wondering what the sunglasses have been for this whole time!
Oh, there are?
But these were not your run-of-the-mill guards.
They were Japanese mercenaries.
Were they also tougher than normal guards?
No way!
On the contrary.
They were weaker.
One punch and down they went.
But these Japanese mercs were damn perceptive due to special training they received.
Their unique awareness was twice that of a normal guard.
An angle of 180 degrees.
Getting close to them unnoticed was impossible if you weren't behind their back.
I see.
Oh, and that guy is running?
Okay.
So this guy can see the whole hallway, essentially, is what you're trying to tell me.
The guy next to- the guy down here can see the whole hallway.
Oh, that is not- I meant to press F.
Hey!
A coin!
Nice.
I felt like I bullied the guy.
He speaks English?
His name is Maikuru.
Why wouldn't he speak English?
He speaks English?
Okay, that's just saved.
That's all.
That's all I wanted.
Okay, that's just saved.
That's all.
That's all I wanted.
Like, not only did I just punch it- take him down in one hit, but he flew, you know?
He flew, one punch, man.
Yeah, oh!
Okay, okay.
Let's see, how do we want to take out these guys.
I think I get- I did get my coin back.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Let's see- how do we want to take out these guys?
So, I'm gonna switch to the other way around.
I'm gonna save my coins.
Just like one of my Japanese animes.
How do I get out?
So he just goes up and down?
That's it?
Oh yeah, their name is Mike, not Michael.
Mike.
Literally just Mike.
Mike is Mike.
That's a full legal name.
Maikuru.
Maikeru.
If I throw a coin all the way down here, will he notice it?
Where'd my coin go?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I got it.
That would have been so sad.
I think I'm about to get noticed.
Oh shit.
Wait, I just noticed that...
Oh my god, there's so many of them!
The alert can go down.
I just noticed the alert can go down, but...
Does this one have three guys?
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Yes, there's three guys here.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk!
Got him.
And potty?
Yeah!
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk!
You need to go here.
You go, actually, over here.
Oh my gosh.
Mike, you made such a mess!
Yeah, okay.
Alright.
Let's just save again since I've taken out two guys.
I know I'm a save scumming, but, you know...
It's easier that way.
I didn't realize he was right there.
This is why we save scum, everybody!
So, did you wash your hands before using the potty?
Let's try and go for this guy.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, he's right there.
Oh my gosh, he's right here.
Oh, he's looking my direction.
He's gonna turn around.
I'm sorry!
It's so funny.
They sound so pathetic, too.
When you knock them out, they're like...
Just...
Dang it!
I didn't think he'd turn around.
Fine, take me out.
Take me out.
Just take me out.
No.
So, it is possible.
But, like, how is it possible to end the alert?
Maybe if it's like you go into a cutscene.
Like, it has happened once.
Just once.
You know, where we went to a cutscene and it ended the alert.
But...
I
heard something.
No, you didn't.
Oh, wait.
He's gonna see his body, isn't he?
Uh-oh.
I think I messed up.
Oh, no.
Now they're both awake.
Ah!
Use my slingshot.
Oh, that might be good.
That is true.
They are one hit.
Let's see if it works, actually.
Actually, I think for this part, it might be better to...
This guy is staring at me.
He just doesn't realize.
He doesn't even know.
He doesn't even realize how much he's staring at me right now.
Yeah, like that.
Oh, but...
Then how do I get that guy over there?
Hmm...
I think we have to go the other way.
I'll try it, though.
Let's try it.
Why not?
Coin him?
Oh, I guess you're right.
Hey!
A coin!
Actually, I want to go back to the chloroform.
Thank you, sir.
I've gotten pretty good at that, if I do say so myself.
I've gotten pretty good at putting guys to sleep, if I do say so myself.
I can't tell if they can see behind these or not.
Oh, no they can't.
Okay, cool.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
And then, ah...
Put you...
All right, there.
Anything?
Nope.
Professionel.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
I thought I was on the coin.
Um...
Okay, so that room...
Oh, there's a bathroom.
Perfect.
I think we're okay.
Yippee!
We're all good!
Yeah!
Who do you about?
Oh, you missed a lot?
No worries!
We're doing it.
I think after this we have just one more chapter, right?
So...
Wait, did I hit...
No!
I didn't hit the room on the right.
Where am I crazy?
I can't remember...
Leud bones!
Thanks for 4 months!
Thank you!
All the way on the right, right?
We didn't go to... here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
These guys.
Yeah, there's a room over here.
Let's coin them.
I think if I get this guy well, too...
Then I will be able to...
Yeah,
I'll be able to level up!
Yippee!
Yeah!
Light munitions expert.
Increase your maximum ammo.
Heavy munitions expert.
Heavy.
I think heavy.
What's in here?
Some grenades!
Much in time.
Very cool.
I'll take it.
Oh!
Bullets!
Just kidding.
Heavy, heavy, heavy.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Okay, well...
At least we saw what was over here.
Instead of ignoring that room.
So, let's go to...
All the way back.
To all the way...
Back.
Follow your dreams, Heavy Gunner Minto.
Thanks, Ham.
I'm Heavy Gunner.
We'll save again real quick.
Dun, dun, dun, dun!
Yeah!
Hefty, hefty, hefty!
Wimpy, wimpy, wimpy!
Do you guys remember that commercial if you saw it?
I think it was about...
Toilet paper?
Oh!
I am Takuma Takagashi.
Great Japanese samurai warrior.
Alien of Shinra Rex.
If you're the boss of those vessels, know that they couldn't take two punches.
You insult Japanese culture.
You die.
Boy, my katana.
I don't know how to feel that.
I'm going to show you what I think about your damn karate.
Karate.
Takuma Takagashi.
Wait.
Tohu?
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god!
Wait a second.
Hold on.
Oh.
Ouch!
I think I need to shoot him.
Unless he deflects my blades.
Ouch!
I'm going to die.
It's fine.
Maybe... Don't have that happen.
Okay.
I feel like he'll deflect my bullets though, right?
I feel like he'll deflect my bullets or something.
But they gave me a lot of them.
I don't know.
Let's just try it.
I didn't even get to have a single hit in, so...
It's probably fine to try.
It's probably fine to try at least.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, nevermind.
Ouch!
He's healing!
Wait, was he healing himself?
Oh my gosh.
This is not good.
Don't come any closer!
You scared me.
Stop running around!
Oh, that was good.
That was good.
Okay.
Just barely missed.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
No worries.
Actually, I'm going to...
Let's do this real quick.
We're going to...
Oops.
Use that and have...
this up and then re-save.
Just like that.
Does the roll avoid the strikes?
I do not know.
There will be blood!
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
That was close.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Every time I shoot him, he does the...
He does the blade attack.
So maybe I can't do it multiple times or else I will...
Oh gosh!
He still even got me.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
What is he doing?
He's like...
What?!
This is so...
messed...
up!
Oh, I'm going to die!
I'm going to die!
He does heal, right?
He does heal, yeah.
Oh, this one's hard!
Because the...
What the...
What's that metal at the bottom?
I just noticed it.
Founder?
Before his head is apart.
Oh...
Yeah, he's...
Can you roll under the fans?
Okay, let's try it.
Yeah, I forgot to roll.
I always forget to roll.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's a...
Oh, I missed.
What the hell is this head part?
You piece...
What is this?
Ugh!
Oh my god!
I almost...
Please...
Okay.
Oh shoot!
I can't tell where my hit bar is at all, you guys!
This sucks!
Not with these things, they suck!
Okay, hold on.
When he does it again...
Oh my god...
It's such a... okay.
I guess I... can?
The shadows?
Yeah, but the shadows also hit my head!
That's the issue.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I don't think I'm gonna have fun with this fight.
I'm just gonna say that.
You
bitch!
And then every time... oh, come on.
No, I'm just gonna die.
Every time he...
Hits... he does a slash on me.
I have to... I have to bandage.
Every time.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We're gonna do slow and steady as we can.
I think... is the best... course of action for this.
I don't... he runs around too much for me to grenade him.
I think shooting is my only option.
Even... he's too fast for me to rocket him.
Also... I don't think there's any point to me rocketing him.
Because... I only have two.
So...
Yeah, we'll just go with what we got.
Okay.
Piece of...
I
have to reload eventually.
I should've never... I should've gotten the reload thing, you guys.
I should've...
I should've gotten the reload thing.
The automatically reloads.
I hate this!
If you get too close to him, everything sucks!
Everything is bad!
Oh my god.
Wait.
I was reloading!
I couldn't move!
Oh, this is so...
This fight is already so awful annoying.
Oh my god.
This is already so annoying.
I really... I will try grenading him, but I really think he's too fast for it.
I really...
Oh, well.
That was...
Great.
Oh my god.
I... I hate...
I hate these fans.
I can't get... Okay, hold on.
See?
Why did that not hit me, but before hit me?
Why did that one not hit me?
But that one hit me!
I don't understand!
The hitbox is so weird!
Do I just have to roll every time?
But rolling also... Like, I can't...
See?
Okay.
If I spam...
V?
Do you hear that?
That's how little... I can roll.
Like, it's not like a very consistent... There's a... There's a cooldown.
So, it's... It's not as easy...
as... as just like, spamming roll.
Huh?
Thank you for watching!
What the?
He... He sliced my grenade.
He sliced my grenade.
I have to be in a... good, like... Oh my god, you beast!
Oh my god, even if I just get, like, two feet away from him, it's so unfair.
Oh.
Oh, I
need to reload.
I need to reload, but I can't get close to him.
I need to reload when he heals.
Basically.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my gosh, my finger placement!
Are you kidding me?
Right now?
Are you for real?
For real?
This is the worst.
That was just the worst.
This is the worst!
Nooo!
Grenade him when he heals, maybe.
Oh, maybe.
Oh my gosh.
This is where people are just like, when are you gonna play, like, Souls games?
This is why I'll never play them!
Oh my gosh!
Oh
gosh!
I forgot to change into the grenade when he was healing.
You asshole!
You are such an asshole!
I'm going to bleed out.
It
still didn't work!
Okay, it doesn't work, you guys.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't work ever!
He's already at full health.
He's already at full health, man.
This is so messed up.
Okay.
I'll show you guys.
Because rockets are really slow.
I really...
And I only have two of them.
You guys keep saying rockets, but I don't think it's going to be worth it.
I don't think it's going to be worth it.
Rockets are hella slow.
And this guy is zooming.
I can't get close enough to punch him.
Oh, see?
He sliced it!
Okay, we...
That's it.
We know.
He sliced the rocket, you guys.
We can't do rockets.
So, if I see another rocket suggestion in the chat, I'm going to freak out.
I'm going to throw up all over my laptop.
And I'm just going to... I'm just going to...
I'm going to... I'm going to... I'm going to throw...
I'm going to throw up all over my laptop.
Oops.
I didn't mean that.
I got... I got scared.
Oh, shit.
I meant to shoot him.
Concentrating.
I need to recharge.
Shit.
We're just running... We're both like...
Running around like gerbils right now.
Don't even be like...
Shit.
I didn't mean to reload.
I don't have any more health.
I have to... I have to let this heal.
I have to let this heal.
Before I, like, take any more risks.
You know?
He's so fast.
This isn't even Phase 2, you know?
Like, this is just regular...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I have to heal more.
But I can't let him heal, you know?
If he starts healing, I gotta take him... I gotta take him out.
Slow and steady.
Oh my god.
No.
Stop it!
Are you kidding me?
Come
on!
That's not even fair!
That's so unfair!
He should have a cooldown as well on, like, the...
On him...
What's it called?
Him doing the slashes.
Not this slash, but the...
Like, the ones when he's close to you.
Like, the fact that he can just...
Infinitely slash you...
Is very unfair, I think.
And there does... It does, like, insane damage, so it's like, okay...
I guess I'll just die at that point.
For real.
Like, there's not even a point...
To trying at that rate.
See?
And then I just get... I get hit again, and I...
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
I'm just
gonna...
Is it two free shots at the...
I think it's really just more like one, right?
Okay, there you go.
I guess...
I guess that's two.
Oh, whoops.
I thought I was facing up.
But there's, like, no downside to him doing his little blade.
Ah, shit.
See, yeah, you can only get one here.
Oh, that was close!
Yeah, there's no point in doing a...
Double shot there.
Because I'll always get hit.
Yeah.
He counters so fast.
Oh,
I'm bleeding out.
I only
have one left.
I tried to press up.
My finger slipped, though.
There's an attempt.
There was...
Oh.
There was an attempt.
Oh my god, he's healed so much, though.
He's healed so much, though.
Oh my god!
No!
I'm stressing, you guys.
I'm panicking.
And it's making me throw.
The pu territories...
Children, children, children...
That's...
Ah!
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
Shit, shit, shit.
Don't get me, please.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please, please, please.
It is not my honor.
Just die.
Boss defeated.
Ah, I beat him.
Look at all my bullets all over the place.
Here, I'm going to heal real quick.
I'm also going to get some tea because I do be shaking.
Give me one second.
I don't think the cake was good breakfast, you guys.
You're absurd.
The only other food I have...
The only other food I have here are some...
Pretz.
They are...
What's it called?
Sweet potato flavored pretz.
So, I will eat some of those.
I don't want anything sweet right now, though.
Did the rockets help?
No.
The corn pretz?
Oh, yeah.
I've had the corn pretz.
I've got to go around.
Bam, bam, bam.
How do I get this box?
How do I get there?
How do I get to there?
Hmm.
How do I get there?
Save?
Oh, it's saved after I beat him, did it not?
It's saved.
I'll save just to make you guys feel better.
But I did save once I...
Once I beat the boss.
But I'll save to make you guys feel better.
Actually, can I go through here?
Oh, I can.
There we go.
Yeah, there we go.
That works even better.
Better save than sorry.
Ho, ho, ho, ho, hoi, hoi, hoi.
Oh, I also want to get back my...
Oh, there we go.
How do I get that?
Hmm, do I roll over here?
Is that a ladder right there, even?
This is maybe a little extreme, but...
Just kidding?
Hmm...
Mike!
You scared me.
Yeah.
It's me, Mike.
Aww.
What?
You need some help?
Nah, I'm going to the rooftop.
Almost there.
Just take an elevator up a floor.
Okay.
I know.
I was just... exploring a little.
Yeah.
Anyway, if you need any help, come see me.
I'll be around.
Okay, Mike.
See you later.
See you, Mike.
Yup.
Toodaloo.
Toodaloo!
Oh, Mike.
Do you have a key card?
Can you open this door for me, Mike?
Wait.
Oh, um...
Mike.
Um...
Try seducing him.
Mike.
Oh, Mike.
Your strong muscles and your big brain.
Can you open this door for me, big guy?
Souls gamer mental arc soon.
Mmm...
Isn't...
Isn't Bloodborne a Souls-like?
Do I just go back to the elevator or...?
Yes.
Oh, I'm boned.
I'm so screwed.
Wait.
I'm so screwed, you guys.
Oh!
Ah!
I finally went out to the rooftop.
Yeah!
As I stepped out, I observed details that would be missed.
Oh, yeah.
But to a trained eye like mine, nothing ever goes unnoticed.
I read mine as Mike.
First off, there was a communication antenna to my right.
Beep, beep.
Right?
You mean on the left?
No, to my right.
I was looking south, so your left is my right.
Yeah.
Of course.
Continue.
Yeah.
Dummy.
Another key detail.
Four guards!
There were four guards.
Oh!
And they were smoking.
Oh.
Ah!
Well...
Oh!
Well, well, well...
Jesse, why are you talking?
What the fuck do we have here?
Oh, no.
Hands up!
You have no fucking idea who I am, do you?
Who the hell are you, scumbag?
I'm the man who's going to shove my boot in your asses so deep...
We're back to Sergeant Jesse.
...that you'll all be shitting leather for a month!
Well, I hope we're back to Sergeant Jesse.
I'm a fucking work inspector.
Oh!
We're the work inspector!
Military Internal Affairs!
What?
Oh, my God!
So, how the fuck is it possible...
Osha.
Osha's here.
...that a goddamn gentleman like me, dressed as a mere civilian...
...really strolled around the whole fucking building?
I'll tell you how.
Because some inept guards decided that instead of being at their posts, they slithered up to the rooftop to hide, smoke, and spew scum.
Spew scum?
It's our five minutes off, sir.
Are you kidding me, soldier?
No, sir.
There's no five minutes off as a soldier!
Mike, sir.
Mike!
Listen to me carefully, scumbag Mike.
I've been...
Scumbag Mike.
...to the General himself.
He is pissed off with all the soldiers in this building.
And I have his permission to ensure each one of you are pissed off.
I just have to make a little fucking check mark, and your precious fucking leave...
He's pissed off, so they get pissed on?
...is never ending hell of cleaning latrines and wiping piss.
No!
So, don't piss me off.
Do I make myself clear, scumbag Mike?
Crystal clear, sir.
Check mark.
What are you chatting here?
Blah.
Gossiping like schoolgirls.
I think this game loves pee.
Disgusting.
Just as much as you guys do.
Imagine if I was a spy or a prisoner...
This guy is an improv...
...who managed to obtain critical information.
...crazy man.
...and I was pretending to be a work inspector in order to steal a helicopter and escape.
What do you think would happen, scumbag Mike?
Sir, it would be a non-authorized take-off...
Yes.
...and it would be shot down by the surface-to-air missiles.
Oh.
And you think he couldn't avoid it?
No, not the surface-to-air missiles.
Only if he disabled the communication with the missiles, sir.
Ah.
I see.
And how would he do that?
Sir, disabling the communication antenna...
I see.
...the communication with all surface-to-air missile batteries.
Uh-huh.
And he just gets away.
What kind of shitty security is that?
That's it.
Mike just explained the whole story.
It's all going into my report.
Heads are going to roll.
Please, sir.
Don't rescind our leave.
We have children waiting for us.
Fuck.
You have children?
I'm just going back to your house and children.
And you're smoking?
You call yourself a father, scumbag Mike?
Scumbag Mike.
I have children.
I have good reason to keep you from your kids.
Shut up.
No.
Please.
I'll give up smoking.
I swear to God.
Swear to me.
I swear.
I'm magnanimous.
I will turn on my eyes...
Magnanimous?
...this indecency.
What does that mean?
...but the day you hold another cigarette will be your last.
Ooh.
Thank you, sir.
Take a look at this floor.
It's littered of cigarette butts, you pigs.
Nasty.
Have you been tossing these without putting them out?
Oh, generous.
Magnanimous.
You'll run the building down.
Just like me.
Not to mess in the pollution.
You'll run the building down.
I'm magnanimous.
And what happens if a passing child gets burnt from these?
Fucking swine.
Lean down, little piggies.
And collect all these cigarette butts with your mouths.
Now.
Yes, sir.
Ew.
Oh, my God.
They actually did it.
Yes, sir.
Now.
Get out of here and go back to your posts.
Yes, sir.
Yay.
This is it.
I have a table at the Communication Tower.
That was so silly.
Wait.
There's no helicopter up here, though.
Unless...
That was something.
I got some metal clamps.
And more metal clamps.
Metal clamps.
This is crazy.
Fox is a legend.
That guy goes hard.
Ah, the wires!
I was just going to blow it up.
Ah!
That's crazy!
Guys, I have to also potty, so...
I have to also potty.
...the bomb solved the enigma.
It read, Communication Antenna Sparky SGL-65B Anti-Vandalism System.
Anti-personnel bomb explode if person attempt cut antenna signal.
Explosion will not affect structure, but shrapnel eject outside literally destroy any person nearby.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Sergeant, do we have anything similar on base?
No, Lieutenant.
But we can request for one.
So it just explodes shrapnel.
Well, continue with your farce, Mr. Fox.
My farce?
For emergency purpose, disconnect antenna.
Prevent explosion by follow KGS-185-U protocol.
And what the hell is that protocol?
The KGS-185-U protocol.
I didn't figure it out at first, but it turns out that I had read that name before.
We got the map!
We got it!
Oh!
Um...
What does the left side mean?
So first we do the red to the gray.
Red to the gray.
But what do we do here?
I don't even have...
Oh wait, do I still have the bolt colors?
Oh I do.
Does the metal clamps have anything to do with it?
Hold on.
Am I like... Oh, maybe I do a metal clamp from those two and then I cut...
Okay, hold on.
So, metal clamp... Oh, sorry.
My bad.
Metal clamp...
Maybe?
It won't let me do it, though.
Like, I can only look at it, but I can't do anything.
Punch it?
Huh?
Am I missing something?
Let's go explore down below and see if there's anything.
Maybe that will show up.
Are you sure this won't break?
This area seems empty.
Too empty.
I'm scared.
I'm scared right now.
Wait.
What's back here?
Nothing?
Really?
Okay.
Oh!
The helicopter.
The helipad.
The helicopter!
Okay.
Definitely not a Hindie.
No.
Why would it be that?
There it was.
The helicopter I eventually escaped in.
No, that's the Harrier.
You inevitably shoot it down.
But, fuck.
If I flew away, the surface-to-air defenses would shoot me down.
Yeah.
I had to disable that communication antenna so they wouldn't receive the command to fire.
A Harrier-D.
This would, instead...
I don't like that sound.
Provide you the pleasure to take me down yourselves.
I don't like saying that, actually.
You bastards.
Actually, I don't want to say that ever again.
Um...
Oh, I need a keycard here.
So, then...
What is the plan?
With the cuts... with the wires...
I feel like I have everything I need, but...
No one responds.
Robert, still there?
Oh, okay.
Punch the helipad.
It's a helipad.
Yeah.
Do I...
But the...
From the sequence of events, it looks like we do not cut first, right?
It looks like we must...
We must cut...
Do the wire stuff first.
Or the clamps first.
You need wires, probably?
We have wires right in front of us.
Why can't I do the clips then?
Do I combine them with something?
Combine them with the instructions!
I thought I was really cooking there.
If I select this and if I start blasting...
I use the bolt cutter to cut the...
The bolt cutters cut the red wire...
What do I combine though?
Maybe this!
Why do we still have the rusty wire if we don't even need it?
Uhhh...
If only there was a diagram that showed us which wires were okay to cut.
If only there was a person in chat with a brain!
Who knew that I was just kidding around!
Is there anymore...
I need more up.
Let's see.
Umm...
Mike was...
Past...
These guys...
Down here...
Then we go past the boss room...
Maybe he knows of some wires.
Maybe he knows.
I'm making this guy sweat.
Because I'm destroying all the...
Air conditioning.
Hey!
Seriously!
Don't know anything!
Hmm...
Let's see...
Okay...
Maybe there's something...
Upstairs...
Or rather...
I ran all the way back here for nothing.
Is there anything else maybe we can destroy?
Perhaps combine wire and clamps.
Drawing has a line between the clamps.
Like this?
I...
Wait...
No...
I tried that.
I...
Is the condenser near the antenna?
Oh, okay.
Let's see...
Open up.
Open sesame.
Break the machines on the roof.
Oh!
I was doing that though!
You mean I actually have to do that?
Like these?
Ah!
I see.
Okay.
So I was actually doing the appropriate thing by being an asshole.
This is why you break everything you guys!
Truth!
I got a grenade slot.
Hey Mike!
And a shortcut.
Let's go!
I'm going to the next room.
Where?
Else?
Well, I know I can combine with you wires with clamps.
But we need three more.
Or two more, rather.
We need three in total.
That air duct looks punchable.
This one?
Ah!
Yes!
Not that one.
This one.
No.
Yes!
Um...
This one too?
Wait.
Is that all we need?
Combine?
Yeah!
We got three of them!
Okay.
We're good!
I still want to know how to get in here though.
Oh!
Oh no!
There's more.
I'm just kidding.
I know how to get in here.
I forgot.
There was a door.
And I don't have the thing.
Okey-dokey!
Let's head back and destroy a thing!
Let's do it!
So...
Yeah.
Okay.
We have the protocol.
We need to combine the red and the gray.
Oh.
I keep pressing the button.
I'm pressing escape for some reason.
Okay.
I use the wire with clamps to connect the...
Connect the red wire...
With the...
White wire...
Okay.
Next...
Is...
The black wire with the green wire!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I keep doing this every time.
What's wrong with me?
I use the wire with clamps to connect the...
Black wire...
With the...
Green wire...
Yes.
And then it's yellow and blue.
Ah!
Okay.
I use the wire with clamps to connect the...
Yellow wire...
With the...
Blue...
I feel like I'm on Dora the Explorer.
Do you know which wires to clamp?
Very good!
Blue wire!
Now we cut...
We cut...
The blue wire.
We cut the blue wire.
I use the bolt cutter to cut the...
I have to check every time.
Oop!
Blue...
Okay.
Now red...
Red and then black.
Red, black.
Black, red, black.
Red, white, red, black.
Black wire!
Whee!
Yes.
And escape!
All good.
Reach the heliport at the rooftop.
Why is that the mission?
What's gonna go wrong?
Nothing's gonna go wrong.
Everything's fine.
Helicopter.
Here I come.
What about the metal though?
You inevitably shoot it down.
What?
But fuck.
Wait, what?
I didn't have the damn key.
I needed it to get the door open.
No, I have a key!
Obtain the helicopter's key.
I have key.
This is probably it.
No key.
What if I...
If I stand on this, do I get smushed?
I feel like I've exhausted everything.
I will try to talk to Mike again.
See if what he thinks could be the case.
Oh!
Hey Fox, are you there?
Yeah.
Here I am, Robert.
I'm here, Robert.
You find a chopper yet?
Yeah.
Found a helicopter, but I don't have the key.
Can't you hotwire it?
I can't even open the outer door.
How smart do you think I am, Robert?
What is Jesse Fox?
No problem.
Let's see if a guard can be tricked into telling where a spare key is.
Thanks, friend.
I can't trick Mike.
He's my friend.
Hey Mike, how did they bring you here?
In a helicopter, like everyone else.
Everyone but me.
Mike, I'm looking for the key to that helicopter.
Yeah.
General X probably has it in his office.
General X.
Is it far?
You're right in front of it.
Oh.
That door?
Yes.
Finally some luck.
But...
But?
What?
It needs a key.
Only General X can open it.
Oh.
Shit.
Can't you use your magic?
Come on, Mike.
Nope.
There has to be a way to get in there.
Come on, Mike.
What if General X like...
A door or something.
What if he dies in there?
Nobody can open it?
Wait.
His office might have another entrance.
A while ago, I was studying the map of this building.
Yes.
And I saw something weird.
Weird.
What was weird?
The office might have another entrance.
It's a private elevator.
It leads to the basement.
To the basement?
Always wondered why he wanted an unlocked private elevator.
Okay.
So you could take the main elevator to the basement.
No.
The labyrinth.
Oh, gosh.
Thanks, Mike.
I'm going to the basement.
Mike.
Wait.
What?
The basement has a fucking maze.
Yeah.
I know.
Take this map with you.
You'll need it to get through safely.
Oh.
Thanks, Mike.
Thanks.
Bye.
What does it mean?
Hey, Fox.
Weren't you searching for a helicopter key?
Not yet.
No.
But I believe...
You called me like two seconds ago.
How would I get it?
Why?
Because I heard some talk on the radio.
They're keeping a copy of that key in a special room.
With an X!
Okay.
Okay, we got this.
Is it the one on the rooftop?
I actually didn't check.
I don't know if it's easier to go this way, or to go out.
But here we can save, so...
I was gonna say, like, through the rooftop.
But, you know, whatever.
Marked with an X marks the spot!
It has to be where it is.
Look at these guys, just lazy, lazy, lazy to sleep on the job.
Where'd those guys go that were smoking?
Okay, to the basement!
To the basement!
To the b-b-b-b-b-basement!
Oh!
To the basement!
To the b-b-b-b-basement!
I wish to enter the labyrinth.
Then say friend in Elvish, and the door will open.
Friend in Elvish?
Shit.
Turns out the mental patient was a fucking Lord of the Rings geek.
Friend?
What person in their right mind knows how to say friend in Elvish?
Well, I don't know the word.
I'm not looking at chat.
Give me a hint.
I'm afraid I can't grant any assistance to this enigma.
What if I grant you a punch in the face of fruit?
Big fruit?
Fruit?
Do you eat it in the summer?
Watermelon?
It lacks water.
Melon?
Melon!
That's how you say friend in Elvish?
For real?
I couldn't see shit.
If that labyrinth was full of traps, I was going to need something to see in there.
Oh no.
Wait!
So now I have to find a flashlight.
My sunglasses.
What the?
Fine.
Bully him again?
Okay.
I'll bully him this time with with cutters.
Hey buddy.
Pineapple!
Cherries!
Orange!
Melon!
I couldn't see shit.
Oh okay.
Dang.
Pineapple!
Yeah...
Um...
Is there anything that we haven't been able to get because we didn't have like the keycard for it or something.
I'm trying to think.
Melon!
Um...
I'm just going to start exploring.
Oh!
We hit this one!
I was like there's gotta be...
Ah!
No.
Okay.
We got night vision goggles everybody.
I was like there was some door I thought that we couldn't go.
Was there any other doors though?
I'm racking my brain.
Um...
We could go in that one.
We could go in this one.
That room looks suspicious.
Melon?
I'm sorry but you have to leave.
Melons!
I don't think there was anything else that I um...
any other doors that I missed.
Well that was easy.
Um...
Any other... on the other floors though?
The other floor had the...
the um...
laboratory.
We went through everything in there.
I think we're good.
Okay.
Yippee!
Pineapple!
Cherries!
Keep going.
Don't make me...
Don't let me stop you.
Wait, where's our night vision goggles?
Oh!
They're applied automatically.
Orange!
Melon!
Oh!
Oh this is quite spooky.
Okay.
Let's get our map.
And a gun.
Okay.
And our map.
Which says...
East.
Oop.
My bad.
Yeah.
Oh I can't even explore?
East!
The first letter was E.
So I took the path to the east.
East.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
I can't even check the other ways?
This looks suspicious.
Okay.
Maybe it's just how it looks.
Oh.
No!
The metal!
Your east or my east?
Wait.
But the metal...
The metal!
The second letter was also an E.
So I took the east path.
I would make an effort to check the map at every intersection as I proceeded.
Yes.
The map indicates the exits of each intersection, not the exits of each screen.
Okay.
Interesting.
Do not disturb.
Is it a mimic?
Okay.
East.
Where am I?
Oh.
I'm above.
There's a ghost!
You guys we have to go east!
We have to go towards the ghost!
Oh.
Um.
How do I get past this guy?
How do I get past him?
Can I shoot him?
Are you actually afraid of a ghost touching you?
Yeah!
Wouldn't you be?
I know what happens when a ghost touches me.
Or not me.
But when I touch someone, I know what happens.
Okay?
Oh.
He's aggroed now.
Uh oh.
He's aggroed.
We got him.
Oh.
I can go in here.
Interesting.
Okay.
So that one...
Now this is our second intersection.
So we go west again.
Yeah.
West again.
Okay.
It's three hits guys.
Three hits.
Oh.
There's a second guy.
Reload.
Which way is this one?
North.
Oh!
Bullets!
Okay.
Cool.
So sometimes...
Wait.
That could be a mimic though.
Couldn't it?
Couldn't it be a mimic sometimes?
Maybe?
More bullets.
We'll take what we can get.
Wait.
There's no intersection here.
So we just keep on going.
There's a ghost there.
Oh gosh!
They're so fast!
Um.
Guys we do...
We're on the second north, right?
East?
I thought you said weast.
We're on the second north, right?
Second end?
Yeah.
Okay.
That's what I thought.
I won't go that way.
Even though I want to.
The floor might cave, you know.
More bullets.
And then this one...
Is the third end.
Okay.
So now we're on the third end.
We go north.
I'll save eventually.
Don't worry.
I'll save right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Actually, I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm gonna go potty for real.
Nothing here.
BRB like a minute.
Okay.
I'm back.
Alright.
Let's take out some ghosts.
Yeah.
I'm back.
Oh.
They just suck my health.
They suck me dry.
See?
That's what happens when a ghost touches you.
So you don't want a ghost to touch you.
Just get, you know, sucked dry.
How do I do this?
So...
I don't remember which one we're on.
This is the fourth end, right?
So we'll go north?
We'll go north, right?
Wait, but there's an intersection.
Wait.
So what if I just run for it?
It worked.
Yeah.
That was close.
Okay.
Now...
We go east.
Wait, huh?
Oh, yes.
We go east.
Okay.
Nice.
Please don't level drain or constitution drain us.
Don't worry.
We go south.
Oh, we're going into the room with the ghosts.
From here...
East.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Going off the different screen...
Allows you to...
To...
Stop the ghost effects.
Holy moly.
This one is east, right?
Another ghost.
Um...
Wait.
South?
Wait, which S and E...
Wait, okay.
We're on the double S's.
So south, south, right?
South, south.
Yeah.
Shoot.
Oh, south.
Okay.
First aid kit.
I'll take it.
South...
Then here, south.
That was close.
South.
Can you punch the ghost?
I don't know.
I don't know about that one.
Wait, I only have...
Oh, I do not have any more bullets.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
We're on the second south, right?
Time to find out if ghosts are punchable.
Yeah, for real.
So I go south again?
Enough to kill one ghost.
Enough to
kill one ghost.
South again.
I did one too many souths.
No!
Oh, gosh.
This is really bad.
Because now I don't know...
Oh, shoot.
I don't know...
Oh, no.
I don't know which one we're on.
This is the...
Okay, hold on.
Maybe I can just remember.
Ah!
Then I go east and...
East and then south.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're okay, okay, okay.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
We're...
Maybe okay.
I'm gonna figure out...
I'm gonna see if they're punchable right now.
I guess we'll figure out if they're punchable.
Like, right?
Now.
I don't think they're punchable!
I go east here and then I go south, south.
I might use this just so I can recover faster.
Just so I can recover more quickly.
Does the slingshot work?
Hopefully...
But it's slow, as you can tell.
It's slow, slow, slow.
It's really slow.
Okay, I hit him once, I think.
It does hurt them, yeah.
What the?
Oh no, it's not just three hits though.
Oh no, no, no, no, no.
It's not just three hits though.
Oh, it is...
Okay, this is quite bad actually.
I don't think it should reset it.
I don't think so.
They reset?
Wait, for real?
Seriously?
Okay, I'm just gonna shoot him then.
It really resets?
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Okay, so from here...
It's south-south.
South...
First I get nice.
South and then...
Prince K, thank you for the five.
You have to thank you!
How many bullets?
Okay, six.
Okay.
Okay, south here.
And then...
North.
Okay.
Then north.
If I'm counting time correctly, according to this game...
We can head-pat Minto for about 20 seconds before she drains all the life from our body worth.
Stop it!
But get the bullets.
Okay, here...
Is...
North...
North.
So double north.
Okay.
North...
North.
Wait, so north here.
Minto...
Punching goes supply to Minto.
No you can't punch these guys.
You can't punch me.
So north.
And then...
This is the last...
North.
This is the last north.
No!
I think something ate me, but I'm not sure what.
Here...
Here... is east.
Right?
Save?
Yeah, good idea.
Oh, we can't.
Because of the ghost down there.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, we're saved.
Okay, we're saved, we're saved.
So now here...
That's not the one I was aiming for, but...
In the end, it works out!
Here we go!
East!
Fifteen.
Okay.
East and then north.
That's
me.
We east?
I go east here?
No, I go east...
I go north here.
Right?
Because we...
We went east here.
And then we went...
And then we go north here.
And then we go...
West here.
Then we go west here.
Yeah.
West, west.
Weest, weest.
Weest.
Double ghost.
And...
Then we go north here.
Okay, we're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
I go north here.
North here, and then we do...
East...
North, north.
East, north, north.
North...
North.
Like turkey...
And...
Turkey!
Almost got all the secrets.
Yippee!
Final chapter escape complete!
Alright guys, this is it.
I entered the secret door and left those dungeons behind.
Ahead of me was a less dank portion of the basement.
Thank goodness.
According to Mike, there had to be an elevator somewhere Yes,
that we will take to leave.
X on the door, yes.
Yes.
Got a hold of the key.
Okay.
What's dank goodness?
What's a dank goodness?
Explore the basement.
Alright, and it's saved!
Escape complete!
Oh, what's this?
We got some C1!
Yes!
The music in here is so creepy.
What is this?
Piano...
This grate is so gross and grimy.
C1, C2...
C3...
Maybe I can blow it up with the C1.
You guys, C2 is overrated.
C3, never heard of her.
There's the X!
There's the X on the door.
It's very quiet down here.
My better half.
You've been featured in quite a few games!
Recently, haven't you?
C2...
Oh my gosh!
It's the commercial with all the AI.
To describe it, it's like a real lady.
But then the background of the commercial is all made with AI.
And then they end the commercial with an AI character of the lady.
What is happening?
Why is it all AI?
Oh!
My bad.
My
bad.
I just, uh...
Um...
Everything is punchable.
Just makes it, you know...
Makes me want to punch everything.
Even if it literally causes my downfall.
Objectively, now that I'm thinking about it, like, I could have looked at that and been like, that looks like a gas tank.
If I punch it, it will probably explode.
There it was.
General X's private elevator.
Yeah.
But it looks like I need a key!
And there's also the door with the X on it.
Let's go back this way.
Let's get more C1.
Why look when you can punch?
What if I exploded with the C1?
What do you think C3 will be like?
Stamina!
I just thought it looked a little suspicious.
Punch everything.
See, this is why I punch things!
Like, there's probably something right here that I need to get to.
Right?
If you hadn't noticed it was a gas tank, you would have punched it anyway.
Yes!
A door marked with an X, just like Robert told me.
There it was.
The secret room where they kept the helicopter key.
Why would they keep a key in such a creepy place instead of an office?
Creepy.
The more I thought about it, the more things fell down the place.
I was gonna say, do we trust Robert?
I had a strange feeling.
Yeah.
Like a gut feeling that something was just...
wrong.
Do we trust Robert?
Because...
we do not.
I don't know if we do.
Let me go check this elevator real quick.
Okay, so we do need a different key for it.
It just saved, so why not look inside?
Yeah, yeah, I just wanted to go check the other area first.
Ah!
Mr. Fox.
Oh my god.
Um...
You have finally arrived.
General X?
The same.
Are you searching for a key, Mr. Fox?
Who told you?
Perhaps one for a helicopter?
You won't find it here, Mr. Fox.
I'm afraid that your contact has betrayed you.
Don't blame him.
He's been the victim of my...
We know.
Right there, in front of me, was General X.
The puppet master of Operation Jericho.
Not only was he a merciless, psychopathic asshole, he was so smart that he could predict my every move.
Okay, I was not reading, so I thought he was going to say he was so sexy.
You had us waiting longer than expected, Mr. Fox.
I did keep you waiting.
I would have come sooner.
That would remove a certain charm, don't you think?
By the way, I brought some company.
Sexy!
I see you're already acquainted.
He's so sexy.
Surrender, otherwise we'll start executing on you.
There were too many people.
If I opened fire, Harris and the Doctor could die.
Let me guess, you're considering the option of shooting, but you know that Harris and the Doctor could die.
Oh my gosh, he's Psycho Mantis!
But that asshole X was a clean shot.
Yeah, we could take him down.
If I shot quickly, I could kill him.
Now you're probably thinking I'm stupid for being so exposed.
And that you can kill me with a quick enough shot.
If you shoot and kill me, that would be the end of the final boss.
Of all of this, you'd be a hero.
Do you really have such a low opinion of my intellect, Mr. Fox?
Shit.
This was part of his plan.
He was here on purpose.
I was thinking that he might have worn a bulletproof vest.
The name for the face.
By now you should be thinking that I'm wearing a bulletproof vest.
Shooting an armored man would be foolish, don't you think?
He read my mind once again.
But even if his body was covered, his head was not.
One bullet between his eyes and goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait.
But you're not a quitter, Mr. Fox.
It's only logical that you'd consider shooting me in the head.
Oh my god.
Just shoot him while he's talking.
An Olympian trial of marksmanship.
Reflexes and luck.
Let me spare you the trouble.
Sergeant.
Yes, sir.
Shoot me in the head.
Point blank range.
Sir.
That doesn't sound like a mic.
Yes, sir.
That doesn't sound like a mic?
Who are you?
The bullet went through his head.
But the bastard was unfazed.
Return to your post, Sergeant.
Yes, sir.
Oh, could you do that again?
But, like, take two steps forward?
What you're staring at in awe, Mr. Fox...
It's a hologram.
Yep.
A hologram.
Mr. Fox, and now that it's obvious that you can't kill me, let's conclude the matter of your surrender.
Or are there not enough dead bodies to convince you?
Just give me ten seconds to think about it.
Ten seconds.
Harris or doctor?
Oh...
Oh, um...
Doctor.
She's sexy.
Kill the doctor.
I think we messed up.
Um...
What if I blow these up?
Okay, hold on.
Whoa!
We have so many.
Minto, how could you?
I didn't know.
Oh.
How do I use this?
Nope.
It won't let me put it down.
I guess I can only put it down...
Combine them?
To make C2?
Oh!
That's so funny.
That's exactly how it works.
I'm wasting bullets.
No!
Can I make C3?
C4!
We finally have it!
To use the explosive, I needed something to act as a timer.
Ah...
When does it explode?
You're a genius, Minto.
Thank you.
Maybe I go to the...
No, um...
A close friend just passed it asleep today.
Aww, Jeff, I'm so sorry.
Aww...
I hope you're okay.
Check it.
It's gonna explode on me!
Punch it.
It did save.
Huh?
Let's just go.
Hmm...
We can skip all of this, though.
Mr. Fox.
Skip, skip, skip.
Shoot and shoot, shoot.
Skippy skip.
Oh, oh, uh-oh.
Um...
Watch out!
Have you already made up your mind, Mr. Fox?
Oopsie.
Yes, I've decided that.
Watch out!
Behind you!
Did you seriously think that I'd fall for such an old trick?
For the record, I warned you.
Watch out!
Doctor!
Doctor, doctor!
I'm fine.
What happened?
An explosion.
The guard behind you... Me!
...received the brunt of it.
Colonel!
The Colonel, though.
We're gonna have to carry that guy.
Probably.
He's alive.
Okay, good.
Looks like he just blacked out.
We have to leave before reinforcements arrive.
I'm taking Harris with me.
It's best not to move him.
Oh.
We don't know if he has any fractures or internal wounds.
I'll take the risk.
He can't stay here.
It's true, it's true, it's true.
Leave with the Colonel.
Okay.
I'll teabag him a little bit.
Let's go.
Come on, Doctor!
No!
Doctor!
There are injured that require my attention.
She's doing a doctor.
And I don't want to leave my father alone.
What?
They were going to kill you.
She's a doctor.
It was just a trick to catch you.
And if I leave, my father won't work and they'll kill him.
Run!
Go away!
I'll come back for you with the cavalry.
You have my word.
I left that room carrying the Colonel.
On my back.
Wait, you're saying that you managed to rescue Colonel Harris?
Yeah!
That's correct.
Well, Mr. Fox, let's see what you invent to remove him from this story.
Lieutenant, we found a corpse in the remains of the helicopter!
What?
Who is he?
We don't know, Lieutenant.
It was totally carbonized by the fire.
Oh, my word!
Just for this guy to burn up!
Yesterday.
Do you understand me, Wachowski?
Yes, sir!
Fuck.
We killed Colonel Harris.
May God forgive us.
No, he's not Harris.
The Colonel died a month ago in an ambush.
No!
These are his personal belongings.
His dog tag.
His watch.
I'm telling you.
Don't you remember, Sergeant?
We found them on his corpse.
That man has never seen the Colonel.
He's just trying to confuse us with his lies.
Fuck's sake.
He has absolutely no evidence for what he's saying.
I have the body.
OK, I've got this.
What do I have?
What is that?
But...what?
If I'm not mistaken, it's a graduation ring for the 48th commission of officer-candidate high school.
Metal Gear plot plotting.
The Colonel Harris graduated in the 48th commission of officer-candidate high school.
Sgt, you don't believe him, do you?
I do.
With all due respect, sir.
I only said that the Colonel Harris graduated in the 48th commission of officer-candidate high school.
Yeah!
Smell?
It smells like... turkey?
Oh, shit.
Wow, he got really excited.
He was like, it smells like shit.
I'm gonna smell it.
Mr. Fox, continue your story.
Let's see if we can finish this once and for all.
I just continue on without that information?
With knowing that now?
Oh,
shit.
They're all bleeding.
I don't have enough.
I messed up, I think.
I think I messed up.
Oh, wait.
I knocked only one of them out.
I can do this.
How do I knock one of them out?
Oh, never mind.
No, there's three of them.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Ouch!
Oops.
Oh my gosh.
I keep pressing the wrong...
Okay.
Come on.
Let's go.
Maybe... maybe we go up here, actually.
Nope.
Do we... is there anywhere to go in here?
The secret room!
We can hide in the secret room!
Okay.
Can I go see her?
Madam, I'm hurt... I'm injured.
Can I have your first aid kit, please?
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, shoot.
I mean, don't.
I mean...
Dang it!
Close.
I know.
It's too slow.
Okay.
If they come here...
Oh, wait.
I already had it attached.
Okay.
Hmm.
Maybe if I, like, ambush them first, you know?
Like, I make them come to me?
You know?
Like this?
Like, come here!
Like so?
You know?
Just run?
What do you mean, just run?
How am I supposed to get past them, then?
With this guy?
I'm too slow!
To the rooftop.
Right?
There we go!
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Oh, no!
Oh, not a big deal.
Hey, friend.
Don't look at me.
I haven't killed anyone.
I'm not your friend.
For fuck's sake.
Shut up.
Wachowski.
Send the bullet to Science Officer Hollister for analysis.
And tell him to collate it with the gun Mr. Fox had on him.
Maybe we'll have a surprise.
Oh.
I want the results of that five minutes ago.
Understood?
Oh, my God.
This guy!
Yes, sir.
I ran it five minutes ago.
Uh...
Wow!
That asshole General X had some cool music equipment.
On Metal Gear.
Multi-band equalizer, auto-amplified subwoofer, and...
No way.
Double-deck cassette player.
Oh my god.
Fuck, you could record directly from one cassette to another.
Oh my god, Wes, are you for this?
Super tight!
I see a water closet.
I also see...
That's our way out, I believe.
Oh, wait.
Where's that a secret room?
Hold on.
Hold on, Colonel.
One second.
One moment, please.
Why do you...
Oh, break all toilet doors!
I'm a menace!
I won't let anyone pee in peace.
Nice.
We need those for sure.
Oh, what's this?
Hi.
This is your netpick friend.
Welcome.
Welcome to the digital mini art book of Unmetal.
Unmetal is actually a port of an MSX game I created called Prisoner of War.
This is an early version of Unmetal's graphics.
At first, the action took place during the day.
After some thought, I asked Marcel to try a night version.
I liked it much more, and that's why Unmetal takes place overnight.
Does this look familiar to you?
Yeah.
This is the first mock-up for the intro that pays homage to the A-Team.
Oh, look at them!
At the beginning, we created a special screen for the Unmetal rules.
It was removed because it was too annoying.
My first idea was to have playable menus.
You would have to move without being spotted in order to change options.
In the sound room, you had to punch sliding boxes in order to change the volume.
This was all scrapped.
We created Jesse Fox for a project called Afraid.
Unfortunately, the Kickstarter campaign wasn't successful.
Oh my god!
This is the first concept for Jesse Fox.
He was a badass guy who was forced to work for a non-profit as an 8 TV driver.
But that's not how he is now, right?
We didn't just get spoiled, did we?
Jesse has 740 images spread over 210 animations.
There are more than 3000 images for the animation of all characters.
The Unmetal logo evolved over time.
At first, we had a metallic logo that was inspired by 80s military movies.
For the public demo, we changed the title to a more minimalistic version.
In the end, I felt something was missing.
We tried a chromed version of the letters.
This would be the definitive version.
Wow!
When releasing a game, some artwork couldn't be good for marketing.
Here's a mock-up of Jesse preparing to fight a tank.
Yeah!
It looks just like that one snake figure.
This is a version that features a closer view of Jesse Fox against the tank.
He's going to need a bigger weapon than a pistol.
Here's another image of Jesse fighting a nuclear...
These would have been great for thumbnails.
Pretty sure you find it familiar.
Oh, the nuclear sub.
By the way, good job.
Thanks!
A lot of the publisher team enjoyed the cat joke.
The artist seemed to like it too.
We made this mock-up inspired by it.
Oh, the shadow is a cat.
That's so cute.
This mock-up was a first attempt for an un-metal cover image.
Then there was another attempt.
That we actually preferred.
So we chose it.
It is...
It...
We chose it and it...
The artist made a full HD poster.
This would later be un-metal's official cover.
Bob.
Bob, seek help, please.
Before those mock-ups, there were earlier covers.
This is the original one from Marcel, un-metal's graphic artist.
Whoa!
This is a more photorealistic version from Patrick.
A former mate in Ubisoft.
Holy moly.
Last but not least, the cover created by Carol for un-metal.
We used for the box art and the PlayStation Vita.
Even Enrique Carmina, the actor who gives voice to the Spanish version of Jesse, did his own design.
After the Vita release, we improved some parts.
For example, we added vapors, water movement, garbage, and other details.
Yeah!
We animated trees in the jungle.
Updated bullet visuals from white dots.
And finally, we improved the water from the river.
Oh...
Ah!
Oh!
This looks like a spoiler.
That's all.
I hope you found it interesting.
Thanks for playing my game.
And good luck with the final boss fight.
Oh, thank you!
Thanks!
Oh!
Fuck!
I found out that bastard kept a fully stocked armory behind his office.
That sounds good.
I feel like I'm gonna need this for a final bo- for what could be a final box fight.
I'm just saying.
You know?
Could be great to have.
Oh...
Oh my goodness.
Hell yeah.
Lots and lots of bullets left though.
Okay.
Cool!
Colonel, you good?
Okay.
All right.
Final boss fight, maybe?
You picked up more than two rockets.
Yeah, because I got an upgrade earlier.
I got an upgrade that allowed me- I wish I could have upgraded to level 10.
Oh.
Sorry.
I think I need to have him to go.
Wait a second.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no.
My bad.
Here we go.
I wanted- No!
I- I'm trying to punch it.
Oh!
But I guess it doesn't matter.
Okay.
I should heal all the way.
10 is max if you were wondering.
I figured it would be.
I should probably finish healing though, shouldn't I?
Before I go down there.
You know?
I'm healing really slowly though.
So... I'm healing sooo slow!
I wonder what the final perks were.
Fight the potted plant.
This one.
We're so close to being...
Full health.
Like so... Just a little bit more.
Punch the music?
I tried.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't do anything.
Okay.
Here we go.
I do still have God Mode!
What does that do again?
Grants limited invulnerability.
Come on, Colonel!
Okay.
Here we go.
Jesse here.
Do you copy?
I hear you.
Oh, there's more!
I finally reached the last floor.
Oh my god.
Lieutenant, we already have the ballistics results.
Oh, fast!
And?
You are right, sir.
Ballistics established that the bullet was fired from Mr. Fox's gun.
You killed Colonel Harris!
No!
You bastard!
Oh my god.
Sergeant, behave.
Sir, permission to execute that assassin!
No!
Permission denied.
First off, we can't confirm the identity of the victim until we have the forensics report.
You killed Kenny!
Second, according to policy, Mr. Fox has the right to finish his story.
You bastard!
Mr. Fox, continue.
Continue?
You better not contradict the evidence we're collecting.
No!
What are you trying to say, huh?
Okay, save.
Mr. Fox, leaving so soon.
Mr. Hound.
That's not very neighborly of you.
And what's that on your shoulder?
That's personal property, Mr. Fox.
Haven't your parents taught you never to steal?
Steal?
General X stood in my way.
Oh gosh.
Assuming it was really him, and not another hologram.
Okay.
Are you asking yourself if I'm another hologram?
I hate this guy!
Yeah?
No, not this guy.
Oh, okay.
It is I, in the flesh.
Why were you projecting from before?
Now, put a bullet in my head.
Yeah.
You read my mind.
Please tell me, Mr. Fox.
Oh.
How does one shoot that which they cannot see?
What?
Do you like my new device, Mr. Fox?
No!
Well, do you like my sunglasses?
Optical electronic holo-camouflage.
The latest in nanotechnology.
Not the nanotechnology.
Obviously, if you start firing randomly, there's still a chance I may be hit.
All right.
I believe dumb luck is a concept you're fond of?
Self-camel.
So, if you don't mind, I invite you to spend some ammunition with some friends.
No!
General X!
Oh, wait.
Rusty Wire.
What did I do that with?
Okay, select.
Aah!
Wait, how did I destroy this thing before?
Ouch!
Wait.
What about my gun?
What happened to my...
Where did he go?
He's taking my stuff.
Okay, I don't think the sunglasses does anything.
I don't think the sunglasses does anything.
I don't think the sunglasses does anything, so we probably need to just heal.
Where is he?
Oh my god, that was so... I was gaming?
For real?
Oh gosh, I... He stole my... Oh, he stole my ring.
Oh my
gosh, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Wait,
what are you talking about?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I do have grenades.
I don't want to use them.
What the hell is this?
Oh my god.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm going to bleed out.
It's the real Metal Gear.
Okay, I kind of get the fight though.
Maybe I should just use this immediately.
But like, also I feel like it's kind of a waste, right?
He's going to steal it.
My EMP nades.
These ones?
But for what?
For... for... for what?
For his cloak?
But I would have to... I would have to...
Make sure it's... it's... um...
He's in the spot though.
Okay, Alexi, you don't have to be an asshole about it.
Gosh.
It's just that I would have to know where to aim it.
And that's the issue.
Gosh, you don't have to be a smartass about it.
Gosh.
What if I just fight normally?
How... I have it.
As...
I'll try.
I guess I'll try.
I guess it doesn't...
I guess it doesn't hurt, but...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that was me dropping the guy.
I just realized.
Wait, how can I... Oh, if I combine it with the ring, right?
Okay, and then if I...
Oh, I already have it.
Okay.
So...
Hyah!
Oh, hyah!
I think I was playing it correctly before, but you guys want me to play like this, so...
Hyah!
Did I... did I do well?
Oh, but this is how you guys wanted me to play it.
Are you sure?
Oh, my bad.
This is how you guys wanted me to play the game, so I'm just doing what you guys asked me to do.
Chat was wrong?
No, it's definitely like a skill issue probably kind of thing, right?
What if I like...
Can I use this?
No, I just get hit.
Anyway...
I didn't ask you to get a hit, soldier.
Perfect.
That's why you're the boss.
Okay.
Alright, anyway.
I'm gonna shoot the drones instead.
And just let him...
Just let him take my stuff.
Oh, shoot.
Ow!
I pressed the wrong... button, you guys.
For real.
Oh, shoot.
My... I thought my hands were in a different placement.
Oh, I thought I was...
There we go.
Ouchie.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Good.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
This is not good.
Okay, though.
Do you have many bullets left?
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I suspect you stashed some grenades there.
He took my potty!
Oh, gosh.
This is... This is where I'm kind of probably in real trouble.
Yeah!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
I... I was... I was pressing... I was pressing roll, but it was the cooldown.
It was the cooldown.
The blood bag!
You're right.
I do have that.
Mr. Fox.
No!
My potty!
I'm trying to get to them before they...
Before they start shooting at me.
Do you have many bullets left, Fox?
Oh, yeah.
I imagine not.
Still fill all the potty so he can steal a full one.
That sounds awful.
I'll try it.
I don't think it works.
Oh, gosh.
It just doesn't really help when...
Oh, my gosh.
When I get hit every time.
Oh, I don't know how to... Wait.
I don't know how to avoid these, actually.
Wait.
I don't know how to avoid them at all.
I am rolling.
Roll to the opposite of the gun.
Okay.
So, like, he starts blasting and I go...
I think I should stick with the grenades.
I'll be honest.
Oh, uh...
Oh,
shit, shit, shit!
Oh, my God.
Oh, I can't.
I can't, like...
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die.
Actually, yeah.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna die.
I'm not gonna make it.
I... I think I just blew up on my own.
Grenade!
Are you kidding me?
No!
I... I was in the direction.
That's so messed up.
But...
Come on!
Just kill me.
I don't wanna... This isn't the run.
No, just kill me.
Just kill me.
EMP does work on un-metal gear?
But it didn't do anything when I tried it.
After that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did I do it too early?
Oh.
I don't know.
Did I?
You son of a bitch.
Not my hanky!
It has all my mucus in it!
No!
You... jerk!
Oh, shoot.
Well, actually, I wish I could shoot!
I'm not trying to have, like, a perfect run, but I think it helps.
Okay, so...
If I use it...
I don't think punching is very good.
It does work on it.
Okay.
You can easily destroy a robot if you use invisible by combining ring and pyramid, but need luck to not get stolen.
Yeah, it gets stolen very quickly.
So...
I think he just goes in order down the line.
It didn't even...
It didn't even... I'm like...
I'm just gonna die.
I'm just gonna die here.
I honestly don't even think I should use it because I am not skilled enough to use it and then go switch to the grenade and use it and not fuck it up.
I think is the...
Is the issue here.
I think is the issue here.
Mr. Fox!
Stop taking my...
You're such a little freak, you know that?
Oh my god.
I hate...
everything.
I hate everything.
I have to be... I would have to be like so fast for him to not steal it.
No, I would have to be so fast for him to like not steal.
Oh, so he took the ring but he didn't take the invulnerability!
You... ahhh!
Okay, so it is random what he takes.
Okay, interesting.
Rockets?
Oh, okay, just so you guys shut up, please.
Oh my god, it worked!
I'm about to die.
Hold on.
Well, you should be low on ammo by now.
Which means it's time to comfortably finish you.
By the way, I'm sure you may have noticed by now...
What the hell?
How did that work?
Okay, chat was right about something.
I took the liberty to follow you around and recover some of my stolen property.
Oh, now it's him!
Oh, I have no...
Guys, the night goggles are... maybe the sunglasses for real?
Okay, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
I have to EMP him?
I do?
Oh, shit.
What the hell?
Even when I shoot at him, it doesn't...
Oh, shit!
I have to EMP him for real?
Oh, it lasts two seconds!
Are you kidding me?
It lasts literally no time at all!
He took my bandages.
This guy took my bandages.
I have nothing to heal.
That is...
That is so narrow of a window, it's actually unfair.
Oh, my gosh.
No way.
I...
There's...
Huh?
Oh, I think I accidentally pressed...
Maybe I can... do that.
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Oh, that's it.
And we're done.
Maybe if I...
I can't even punch him.
How did he get over here?
How did you get over here?
How?
Punching does do stuff.
It's just I have to be able to get there.
Oh, this is so annoying.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I wasn't ready.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm getting... I'm getting really...
Sorry.
It's just 1 p.m.
and I haven't eaten anything.
Let me just eat some of these sticks.
I also thought I would be done by like... I need to leave at 2.
So, I thought I would be done way earlier than that.
To be honest, I have no motivation at all.
If I don't beat it now, I'm never playing again.
So, I don't think that's really an option for me.
Sorry.
I'm just having not such a good day today.
So, I'm just kind of like feeling a little unmotivated.
Did
you steal my goggles?
So, clear?
Oh, he took the God Mode but not the ring.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Come on!
Mr. Fox.
Oh, come on!
No!
Take...
Just...
I'd rather you take my health than...
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay.
No.
That's fine.
Mr. Star.
No!
Come on!
My blood bag!
I keep forgetting that I have that even.
Probably because they gave it to me so late in the game that I completely forgot I owned it.
Looking to my... I pressed up.
There goes the god mode artifact.
So you take the blood bag and...
What's my health at anyway?
This part's so annoying though!
This part's the annoying part!
And I stole my bandages again!
There should be some items that you're not allowed to steal.
I swear.
There should be some things that you're not allowed to take.
It's just not fair.
So I have to...
I have to EMP.
EMP plus gun.
I guess we'll see.
I have to be like lined up, you know?
Let me try a grenade.
It's not gonna be fast enough but...
It wasn't fast enough!
It was not fast enough!
Oh, that's kind of a surprise.
Oh my god!
This is so annoying.
It's a no.
It's in the way of safety?
Yeah, it's in the way of safety!
Oh, oh, that's so fun!
You're such a drunk!
That's just so good!
I
think punching does the same damage than the gun.
This really sucks.
This just sucks.
If I'm not lined up perfectly, I just entirely missed the opportunity!
It's the EMP.
And I'm basically wasting them at this point.
How did you get over there so fast?
That was lucky.
And that's it.
That's game too.
That's game because I don't have any other health.
Unless I can clutch it somehow.
I have no health.
Should
we try the fire extinguisher?
And the game gives you nothing.
It does not give you any more grenades.
It does not give you any more anything.
Just...
Unfair.
Sorry if the dev is still here.
I am really having a bad day.
Usually, my patience is much better than this.
Today, I'm just not here for cheap tricks.
I'm really sorry if you're still listening.
I'm just really not having a good day.
It's so...
If I'm like getting screwed over, I'm like...
So...
Oh, shit.
I'm so annoyed by it.
Ah, fuck you!
Where's the cooldown?
Do you have many bullets left, Fox?
I imagine not.
I suspect you've...
...
OMG.
I have so many bullets...
...
What are you doing?
Some changes have already been made.
I just hide in this far...
There's an awful word I don't understand about enemies.
Also, I wish these guys would come from the same spot, so I could at least time that better.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Guess I'm not doing what I wanted to do today.
Haha.
And it
is!
At the very last second, he stole them!
No way!
It's so unfair.
I don't have the ring anymore, no.
At the fire extinguisher, I tried pressing C.
I don't want to try pressing C.
Unless I know it actually works.
I have a blood pact?
Oh, you're right.
I do have the blood pact.
You're right.
No!
I'm too stubborn!
Let
me see what time it closes.
No!
Not gonna do it in another stream.
Now or never!
No!
I don't want to do it in another stream.
Did he just take one of my first aid kits?!
You managed to injure me, Mr. Fox.
Sincerely, this was beyond my expectations.
Luckily, you've brought my first aid kits.
But you don't mind that you're missing one.
So, you've been stealing my stuff.
Your stuff?
Everything you've acquired is from my base, Mr. Fox.
And as the proverb states, one who steals from a thief will receive a hundred years of pardon.
That bastard had been stealing from me while I was busy destroying his machines.
And I'm sure he was going to steal more stuff as he needed it.
Oh my god, no, no!
I can't.
Could I, like, lace it with poison?
I'm gonna pee all over it!
I'm gonna pee all over your grenade!
Or your first aid kit!
I'm gonna pee all over your first aid kit!
Eat the first aid kit!
I'm gonna eat them!
Oh my god!
If only I had the invulnerability.
What's my health at, anyway?
Oh, okay.
Close.
This is so unfair!
No, this is an absolute...
You won't run out of first aid kits, Mr. Fox.
Unfortunately, you'll be unable to heal yourself anymore.
Fortunately, it also means that you've run out of them.
Which adds to the thrill.
Let the best man win.
I only have four grenades left.
What the fuck?
You bastard!
Mr. Fox.
Did you just stab me?
You complain because I remove your belongings.
And now you complain again when I return them.
What?
Cheer up.
I simply gave back your rusty wire.
Although, maybe I've been a little brusque.
You can find it between your ribs.
By the way, Mr. Fox.
Let's see if you can kill me before bleeding to death.
Good luck.
I do have a blood bag.
What the...
What the hell?
No, I know I'm full.
I know I'm full.
I'm just...
I'm...
I'm shocked right now.
Can I stab him?
You think?
How the hell am I supposed to save?
Oh my gosh.
Fuck you, man.
I don't think the rusty wire does anything unless I'm...
Oh, I have no more.
I have no more.
I think that's it, you guys.
I think that's it.
I think it's softlocked now.
I think it's softlocked.
It's softlocked, I think.
Regular grenades.
What's my health at?
Okay.
I might use the...
You can't hit him without EMPs.
Yeah, I think he can only...
I think he only shows up when I make him show up.
I don't think I can hit him otherwise.
I don't think so.
Punch in his spot?
Okay.
Okay, we'll try.
I don't...
You can hit him when he's shooting.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna use this, though.
Guys,
it's so over.
It's over.
It's so over.
Oh my god.
It's so...
It's over.
Yeah, it's over.
Yeah.
I don't think there's a way to...
Unless I'm gonna grenade him very specifically.
I'm
really softlocked.
I think I only missed like two...
I only...
Like I only missed two shots of...
So I have to be absolutely a hundred percent perfect with the electromagnetic grenades?
Like that's just unfair.
I have eleven.
I think I picked up all that I could.
Use the medkits first so he can't heal.
You have to waste your heals before third phase?
So I have to...
What?
Okay...
Uh-uh.
He already took my god mode.
That's crazy.
I didn't.
Oh my god.
Well, this is one way to use him up, I guess.
This is one way to use him up, I guess.
Before phase three?
So like now?
Oh wait, I think I...
Okay.
And one more!
We use one more!
Oh.
It won't let me use it again.
Use it before he hits two-thirds health.
Okay, okay, okay.
I think he was like over here.
But I'm gonna wait.
Okay.
Wait, I'm not using the gun.
Okay, hold on.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm like getting a little cross-eyed here.
Okay, that was a waste of my time.
That's okay though, I guess.
Nice.
I have underestimated you, Mr. Fox.
Boss defeated.
No.
What are you waiting for?
Finish me?
Time without payin' for your crimes?
What are you waiting for?
No way.
I'll take you to a trial so they can go in the woods.
They condemn you and lock you in a cell to rot for the rest of your life.
I see.
Tell me, Mr. Fox.
How are you going to take me if you can't move?
What?
You're so predictable.
I knew you wouldn't kill me or let me die.
Just like all of my other subordinates, they consistently led you directly into my trap, Mr. Fox.
Honestly, I hoped you were going to surprise me again, like that little spark in the basement.
But once more, the pen is mightier than the sword.
By the way, thanks for volunteering to test my new paralyzer.
The discharge it releases shuts down the whole peripheral nervous system.
Oh, and then we die.
That's it.
You should have killed me when you had the chance.
See you never, Mr. Fox.
Colonel!
Oh my god!
Are you alright, sir?
Don't worry.
The effects on the paralysis will wear off soon.
Ugh, my hands are shaking so much.
But it's not prudent to stay here.
Come on, stand up, Fox.
I'll help you up.
From how hungry are you?
Oh gosh.
I guess I'll go get some easy konbini food after this.
Colonel!
Stage complete!
I had a secret.
What was the secret?
Colonel Harris and I went to the helicopter.
Finish the game!
A few minutes later, when I regained my motor skills, we took off.
Oh my gosh.
Lieutenant, we have the forensic report of the carbonized corpse.
Who is it?
Hand it to the sergeant.
Dismissed.
Yes, sir.
Looks like we can finally prove that Mr. Fox has been lying.
Is that Victory Mail?
I feel like it.
Sergeant, what does the report say?
Freaking did it, you guys!
I said I would and I did.
The physiological study confirms that the corpse with identification C4423...
I thought it was going to be like...
...measures three inches taller than Colonel Alan Harris.
Two to three hours more.
Not this much.
...disproving his identity.
I'll just, uh...
What?
Then he's not the Colonel.
Of course not.
I told you, Sergeant.
Care to explain this, Mr. Fox?
Are you going to tell us that he was tortured on a rack until it stretched him three inches?
That would be ridiculous.
He's not Colonel Harris.
I never said he was.
You what?
You just told us that you both flew away in that helicopter.
I told you we escaped together, but never said that corpse was Colonel Harris.
In fact, I have no idea who it is.
Are you sure you found it in the helicopter?
Did you plan it yourselves to incriminate me?
Like some dirty cops?
How dared you?
Enough games, Mr. Fox.
Enough.
We'll find out who you are and then we'll execute you.
I'm just a guy.
What now?
Colonel!
What the hell is happening in here?
Colonel in the room, salute.
Colonel in the room.
At ease.
Colonel Harris?
You're alive.
Yes.
Sir, we thought you passed away.
As you can see, Lieutenant, I'm alive and kicking.
Why is this man handcuffed?
We were interrogating him.
He's a spy that we captured, sir.
A spy?
Are you pulling my leg?
He's a civilian who was imprisoned for a crime he didn't commit.
He's also the man that not only saved my life and freed me from the ex-army base, but also...
Also?
He found classified information about Operation Jericho that will be essential in stopping the ex-army.
For goodness sakes, that man's a fucking hero.
Release him immediately.
At ease, everybody.
At ease.
Wisps.
Yes, sir.
Did you tell them you're heroic feet, Fox?
I was that when we entered the helicopter, Colonel.
But it looks like they found a corpse in the helicopter.
But, fuck, I don't know who he is.
They say he has a bullet in his head.
And it came from my gun.
But I haven't killed anyone.
That corpse was General X.
I killed him with your gun myself.
Don't you remember?
Yeah, that makes sense.
So you just, like, pulled his body on the helicopter?
See, you'll never, General X.
But where did he get the news from?
From the senses inside the helicopter.
I retrieved General X's corpse and dragged it to the helicopter's aft.
That bastard was heavy.
In the air.
You know what happened.
Hurry up, Fox.
They're following us.
Oh my gosh, he looks like Plissken right now.
Don't rush me, Colonel.
I'm getting used to the controls.
This piece of junk has levers and buttons everywhere.
Wait, so he's literally just a civilian?
But don't panic.
I think we'll be able to reach allied territory before they catch up.
Then I'll call the cavalry.
Oh.
Charlie, Alpha, Charlie, Alpha.
Wait, but then they shoot them down, don't they?
Damn it.
This radio isn't working.
Fucking piece of shit.
Don't worry, Colonel.
As soon as we reach allied territory, they'll stop pursuing us.
Yeah, maybe.
Don't worry.
Son, with no radio, when this fully armed piece of Soviet junk pings their radar...
Oh.
The first thing they're gonna do when we don't answer is dig us down.
If we're in trouble.
Fuck.
So we'll be shot at if we keep going?
Or we'll be shot at when we turn around?
It's just some guy?
Affirmative.
We're between a rock and a hard place.
We'll abandon the helicopter as soon as we cross the border.
Okay.
I'm gonna search for the parachutes.
But jumping would still be risky in this jungle terrain.
Charlie, Alpha, Charlie, Alpha.
We're nearly there.
There's only one, Fox.
You jump and deliver the documents to the allies.
No, Colonel!
Are you insane, Colonel?
They won't believe me.
And you don't know how to pilot this junk.
And why do you know?
You're young.
You have your life ahead of you, son.
Take this ring.
Show it to them.
They'll believe you.
It smells bad.
Fuckin' place of shit.
Why?
But that's because those asshole bastards were going to snatch it as they put their hands on it.
Was that important to you?
So I hid it in the only safe place I had left.
My ass.
Come on, son.
Put on the parachute.
My asthma.
Colonel, you need to jump and tell them everything yourself.
What is going on?
We argued about who had to jump.
And I had to admit that Mr. Fox had one convincing argument.
What's that?
Fox, what are you waiting for?
Hurry up, son.
We are running out of time.
I convinced him!
The next thing I remember was waking up, hanging from the parachute tangled to a tree.
The owner of a farm who spotted me arrived a few minutes later.
I like how the grenades were still the little thing.
He was so kind as to bring me here to the base.
The lieutenant and the sergeant were shocked and immediately apologized.
A few days later...
...
The army decorated me with two medals.
Wow.
Jesse Fox, for rescuing an MIA military colonel and recovering intelligence on Operation Jericho.
I, Colonel Alan Harris of the 5th Battalion, award you a purple cross.
Jesse Fox, you're a big fox?
That medal really exists?
Oh my god, the girl jumped scared me.
It didn't?
They had to invent it.
There was nothing that they could provide for a civilian.
The girl jump scared me.
The girl also awarded a Gandhi Medal of the National Idiot.
Female jump scare.
National Idiot?
Well, I received it because I didn't kill any enemies at all during the escape.
As you know, militaries don't get why killing is wrong.
Well, at least we agree on that.
So, thanks to the documents I found, the allies could find and sink every related submarine.
Ooh!
The military base, docks, and Omega building were the targets of a large operation.
Everyone was arrested.
Where's the doc?
Robert the Paparazzi published the story and won a Pulitzer Prize.
Oh my gosh.
The two doctors and their two fathers dedicated themselves to finding a cure for cancer using nanonuclear weapons.
Wasn't it one doctor?
That's what they wanted us to believe.
The captain of that boat...
Died.
He retired with my 50 million dollars.
But he died of gonorrhea the week after.
Seriously?
Nah.
But, he would have deserved it.
Yes.
Do you remember Private Mike?
The one I found hammered and used to eat my tea?
Yes!
Private Mike!
Well, he could finally visit his daughter for her birthday.
Hello!
Daddy!
And I...
Went back to my old life as a smuggler.
The smuggling!
Wow.
Jessie, that's the most incredible story ever told.
What are we smuggling?
Oh my god, you have an amazing imagination.
You should be a video game writer.
You don't believe me.
Not a word.
Thank you very much, Miss Incredulous.
Hey, who are those guys?
Must be an improvised patrol.
Oh no.
Don't say a word if they don't ask you anything.
The smuggling.
Oh my god, smuggling.
Smuggling.
We're smuggling.
Uh-oh.
Good morning.
May I see your passports, please?
Mike!
Here you are.
Very well.
Let's see.
Fuck.
You're Jessie Fox.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's me.
Holy Jesus.
I can't believe it.
The legend.
Hey, Jimmy.
Jimmy?
Who's that guy?
That's not a Jimmy.
I'm Mikey's Fox.
Oh.
The one who rescued Colonel Alan Harris and prevented the nuclear attacks.
I really admire you, Mr. Fox.
You're a fucking hero.
Thanks, soldier.
Here are your passports.
Thank you.
It's Mike.
Drive carefully.
Hey, Mike.
Are you okay?
You've been very quiet.
Stop the car.
Oh, maybe not on like the side of the cliff, right?
What's up?
Then it's true.
Jessie paid them off.
It's all true.
Now do you believe me?
Kiss me.
What?
Kiss me now.
Huh?
What?
She was turned on by the... by the heroism?
That's how you guys gotta get...
If you want the girl, that's what you gotta do.
You gotta become a smuggler.
You gotta go to the forest.
You gotta get caught by some guards.
And they imprison you for a crime you didn't commit.
What was the crime?
And then you also...
Um, okay.
Part of me was starting to believe that the girl in the seat was his sister.
So...
I'm glad that wasn't the case when we...
When she said kiss me.
Unless...
Don't be so selfish...
Nanananananananananana...
Nanananananananana...
Hanaka.
You know...
But you would.
It's Thank You, She ered me.
Sweet Hope Alabama but for Anime.
That's all you gotta do!
And then you stop the plans... Whatever plans they have going.
It can be... It could be they're learning how to clone...
And... ultra mega dogs... for fighting.
You just gotta stop.
Or it could be that they're trying to find the most...
They're trying to harvest the most delicious potato.
It doesn't matter.
You stop their plan.
Then, you earn a reward.
And then, you get the girl.
And that's it!
Yippee!
Overall, I really did like the game.
You know...
While the final boss was... a little BS...
Once you learn the...
Once you learn the... what you have to do...
Then...
The game wants you to play a very specific way.
And that's okay, you know.
But...
Hmm...
Thank you for playing.
Oh, thanks... Special thanks to you for playing on Metal.
Thanks!
Hey, Jimmy.
Who the fuck is this Colonel Alan Harris?
I don't know.
Yesterday, I met that guy in a bar.
He was nice.
I told him that I was going to slog as a guard here today.
Slog.
And he said if I pretended he rescued the Colonel...
And prevented nuclear attacks when he drove by...
He'd give me a hundred bucks.
A hundred bucks for saying four sentences.
Can you believe it?
No way.
Good morning.
Can I see your passport, please?
He did pay them off.
Good morning.
Here you are.
It's all...
It's a lie?
It's been the easiest one hundred bucks ever.
Fuck.
People make up stupid shit just to score.
Yeah, dude.
No way.
Jesse Fox, I believed you.
He's not only a smuggler of goods, he's a smuggler of knowledge.
He smuggled that... and money.
He smuggled it to the guy and then he smuggled the story to the girl.
Into her brain.
Scammed.
Knowledge smuggler.
We've been swindled.
We've been hoodwinked.
We've been scammed, bamboozled.
I think I need to take notes.
I think.
That's what they want us to believe.
So you're gonna make it to your plans, boss?
If I leave, like, right now.
Maybe.
If I get ready and leave right at this very moment.
Thank you guys!
For letting me finish UnMetal!
I did not think that it would take another five hours.
Something, something, skill issues.
Anyway!
Thank you!
I only have a little bit of time left in Japan.
Probably, I will stream.
Probably come back next, either Tuesday or Wednesday.
I will, of course, let you guys know on Twitter.
And in a schedule.
When I create my schedule for this coming week.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
I'll see you guys when I get back home!
Bye!
Bye bye!
Just a couple days.
Bye!